so last week on a Friday evening
Anheuser-Busch put out a non-apology
statement where they just said you know
we didn't mean to be divisive thank you
and have a nice day they also through
Budweiser released an ad showing a horse
running across America and then winning
or whatever it's called and talking
about Patriots because yeah the boycott
is bad for them they're worried about it
their stock was skyrocketing this month
now it's dipping back down dropped five
points in the past week while comparably
other beer companies aren't doing so bad
they're actually seeing an increase
so don Jr comes out and says everybody
stop you got to stop boycotting
Anheuser-Busch over their sponsorship of
Dylan Mulvaney and he said they actually
donate a lot to conservatives well guess
what happened as predicted here we are
the non-apology statement has resulted
in a backlash where the left has now
come out Whoopi Goldberg Whoopi Goldberg
on The View said to Anheuser-Busch don't
let them scare you let us scare you and
isn't that exactly what I've been saying
for the past two and a half weeks that
Anheuser-Busch needs to issue an apology
to make the statement that they are more
concerned about their own customers
supposedly the people they support then
they are far left extremists
I think the story here is more than just
Anheuser-Busch and Bud Light the story
is the left is is a in my view
victim of the algorithmic Decay we are
seeing who's who's that you
oh so what we are seeing is the
algorithm promoting and manipulating
content making people go crazy and for
no logical reason the view defending
that because they're tribalist zombies
we on the other saying hey the algorithm
is plaguing people's minds making
teenagers depressed and you shouldn't
advertise alcohol uh to minors and for
some reason Whoopi Goldberg is so
angered by that thought she went on her
national television show and said
Budweiser you better not you should fear
us so this is interesting we also got a
bunch of other stories in Chicago for
four nights in a row we had Mass riding
What's called the Team Takeover in Los
Angeles the street takeovers are getting
worse and roving bands of I guess
Marauders are smashing up businesses and
stealing stuff and in Chicago they tried
breaking into the Art Institute and got
shot
wow
what a crazy past weekend I suppose so
we're going to talk all about that
before we do head over to castbrew.com
this show is brought to you by cast Brew
Coffee which is our coffee company
pre-orders are available now and the
coffee is expected to ship by May 5th
currently in production so order it now
you can get your rise with Roberto Jr
breakfast Blend or your Appalachian
nights and then after it officially
launches we're going to be rolling out a
bunch of other Blends and this is a
component of the coffee shop that we
currently have underway we bought the
building it's ready to go they're just
doing Plumbing installation countertops
permitting and other stuff so hopefully
in a few months let's be real six to
eight months we'll have a coffee shop
open in West Virginia and we'll be
selling you cast brew coffee but instead
of taking sponsorship from other
companies we sponsored ourselves so go
to casper.com but also don't forget to
go to timcast.com click that join us
button become a member and then you will
get access to the uncensored members
only portion of the Tim cast IRL show
Monday through Thursday at about 10 10
p.m eastern time every night we need a
few minutes to get it going live after
the main show and you will also get
access to our Discord server where if
you sign up for at least six months or
at the 25 level you can actually submit
questions and call into the after show
out it's a whole lot of fun and the best
part of the day in my opinion so smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends joining us tonight to talk about
all of this and more is Xavier de Russo
thank you for having me who are you good
sir I'm Xavier derusso I'm here from Los
Angeles I'm a prageru personality and
doing everything we can to fight this
culture War I think what's uh was really
interesting about your story is that and
you just basically told me that gist of
it before we went live you were a black
lives matter supporter an activist who
was trying to debunk Candace Owens and
then accidentally debunked yourself
yeah I was casted for a big reality show
I had been woke my entire life my
family's pretty far left and when I was
going on that show I wanted to study all
the current arguments so I made a list
of different things I wanted to debunk
from prageru from Candace Owens and I
ended up dismantling my entire
indoctrination narrative instead so I
backed out of the show and started
speaking on conservative values wow
that's amazing all right well we got a
lot to talk about so thanks for hanging
out thanks for having me we got Phil
Labonte hello I am philibonti lead
singer of All That Remains
anti-communist and counter-revolutionary
how you doing Brett oh how's it going
guys yes my name is Brett dasovic Monday
through Friday I am the host of Pop
Culture crisis right here on youtube.com
it's at 3 P.M I'm sitting in for Ian
tonight I don't quite have his his hair
or his gravitas but I'll do my best
we'll just need you to talk about
graphene at least yeah we've got
graphene here so I can I can channel
that we got that all right right on and
we got surge pressing the buttons yo
what's up guys all right let's jump into
this first story from Yahoo news Whoopi
Goldberg to Anheuser-Busch on
conservative backlash don't let them
scare you let us scare you oh boy I love
I love Whoopi Goldberg in the view just
overtly threatening Terror against uh uh
their political opponents okay I'm being
a bit hyperbolic on that re in that
regard here we go Whoopi gold we're
gonna Coast on ABC's the view weighed in
today on the recent Buzz wire buzzware
Budweiser controversies reminding the
beer maker that as the shows as the
shows ended Navarro said members of the
LGBT community are American two the
conversation follows conservative
backlash and calls for boycott over
their partnership with Dylan Mulvaney
Goldberg beginning the Hot Topic debate
by noting that Budweiser was her beer of
choice before she quit drinking oh
before she quit huh asked what
conservatives are so angry about beer is
not a Democrat or Republican it doesn't
have a belief system it's just beer
well uh I'll tell you I'll tell you it's
because Dylan Mulvaney is the embodiment
of what I call Elsa gate 2.0 the
algorithmic manipulation resulting in
chaotic nonsense content and then Bud
Light was like I got an idea let's fund
more of this Decay and promote booze to
children and so I'm just like bro
everything about what you're doing is a
bad thing but here's the best part the
VP of marketing for Budweiser admitted
their goal was to out Market alcohol to
kids she was like it's a it's an old
dying brand and we got to get young
people like oh is that what you're
saying because Dylan Mulvaney's audience
are like 15 years old you can just
Google it the average user of tick tock
is under 21. that's all that matters and
then obviously Dylan Mulvaney's audience
is not a bunch of 50 year old dudes it's
a bunch of 15 year old kids that's why
I'm mildly perturbed I don't know about
you guys it blows my mind that Dylan
Mulvaney has a an audience of teens I I
don't see what I'm I'm not a team but I
don't see what is actually well
teenagers in my opinion aren't seeking
out
something of of like
they're being recommended things right
they're not walking to a library and
being like and saying like give me
something that's you know in the vein of
a dystopian no they're showing up the
teachers being like here's the book to
read they're seeing the commercials
seeing the ads they're young people I'm
not saying that to be mean I'm saying
young people are learning and developing
and being influenced by their older
peers so what's happening is Tick Tock
is putting Dylan Mulvaney in front of
people more and more people that's why I
don't like that they're giving Dylan
Mulvaney sponsorship
your your argument is that the algorithm
is
being is what's presenting this stuff to
kids but you're all the algorithm
responds to what people continue to
watch right I would say yes and no right
so if you go on Instagram you'll see at
the the algorithm feeding you a bunch of
stuff based on what you like but
periodically it sends me stuff I have no
idea why it said it's testing the waters
with certain content You could argue
that with Tick Tock they put this
content out there and it got a response
right but the reality is we already know
from and now especially from the Twitter
files they put their thumb on the scales
and they choose what is or isn't allowed
and if we go back to the uh Rogan
Experience conversation that I had with
Jack Dorsey and veggie they explicitly
said they were protecting this community
and not other communities so they
outright we're like trans content is
under our overt and explicit protection
that means that if Dylan Mulvaney made
if Dylan Mo Betty came out with like a a
video debunking critical race Theory
it's not going to get play Tim cast IRL
on Tick Tock bam end because they choose
we aren't allowed Dylan Mulvaney gets
protected and or promoted and I'll give
you an example I was talking to these
people last weekend about exactly this
and why Dylan Mulvaney is bad and the
easiest way to explain it is
first regular people like Whoopi
Goldberg and default liberals look at
domovany and they're like it's just a
trans person but Don Mulvaney is not
Dylan Mulvaney I don't believe is trans
I think it's all just part of the
algorithmic machine the example I use is
how young girls are developing Tourette
Syndrome have you guys seen this story
from from Twitter uh I'm sorry from
Instagram and Tick Tock teenage girls
start seeing massive spikes in Tourette
ticks because what happened was a few
young women with Tourette Syndrome got
prominent followings and they would make
these videos where they would be like
sometimes it's it's like and then I'm
trying to talk and then they started
young girl started imitating this
content and actually developing this
social behavior and making more and more
content about it that is exactly what
Dylan Mulvaney is Dylan Mulvaney gets
fed this content tries to make content
that will get Dylan Mulvaney famous
figures it out and it's creating a
feedback loop that is melting people's
brains now with the Tourette thing we
know tourettes is not good we don't have
people coming out being like you if a
child identifies as having Tourette's
you should affirm them no one's arguing
that but when it comes to what Dylan
mulvania is doing they're all defending
defending and arguing for more so here's
where we are I want to just to get the
conversation going
Whoopi Goldberg and The View on the left
has realized
they're losing this one and they have
made it explicitly clear to
Anheuser-Busch fear us
because all all I said was this guys
don't buy Bud Light don't buy
Anheuser-Busch you don't got to go
protest you don't gotta make a phone
call you don't gotta do anything other
than buy a different beer easiest thing
in the world and they know and to
respond to that they have to make sure
they remind Anheuser-Busch that they
engage in violence and Terror as an
anecdote I I've seen some of my friends
that are that that are left leaning uh
have a little pushback on the
the mud you know Bud Light uh
boycott and I feel like that the
pushback is because it's it's effective
and it's not I don't think that it's
going to have a significant effect on
their bottom line it's not going to be a
monetary Victory but it's going to be
something where it's going to inhibit
other brands from doing this kind of
stuff because you know I mean June is
only you know a month and a half in a
way away and it's going to be it's gonna
be you know everything's gonna be Pride
for all the whole month so I think that
this is more about messaging to Brands
hey look you know
at least at least a little bit pull back
on it maybe I guess I think that that's
what they're gonna pick up does that
article also say that beer isn't doesn't
know a political party have they ever
been to a micro Brewery like have you
ever like I if you went and pulled the
people at a micro Brewery about who
their political uh who their political
affiliations are who do you think that
would be
it may not have a political opinion but
it knows that it's better than you at
the very least that's the one thing that
I thought she said that was correct beer
should not have a political party I
don't need every single product that I
get to have a political party attached
to it but what Budweiser just did was
the dumbest thing I've ever done or ever
seen I've never seen a company shoot
themselves in both feet so quickly well
I I would agree with you maybe two years
ago but now I'm like no I demand all of
my products just come out right now and
say Trump 2024 and fly American flags
that's it if if a company comes out and
they're selling flip-flops and they got
American flags I'm buying them because
I'm at a point where I'm sick of people
like Whoopi Goldberg I'm sick of what
Anheuser-Busch did if Anheuser-Busch
just said I don't know or care here's
beer I bet well it is what it is but
they decided to get involved and then
they apparently they give more money to
Republicans Don Jr pointed it out and
said stop boycotting them and I'm like
no no if they if if they know that
Republicans butter their bread to the
point where they give more to
Republicans then they should come out
and say along with the money we give you
we're gonna apologize for pissing you
off they could not even do that but you
said Phil you don't think it's gonna be
monetary I'll tell you what what is what
is bad there's that uh what's that guy's
name Riley green the country singer
we had a story on timcast.com he had a
line in his song where he said the
cooler is always full of Bud Light or
whatever he changed the lyrics and
performance dude they're always full of
Coors Light
and and look some people might find that
silly but that does matter to a brand
you were so iconic that a a famous
country music song referenced your brand
that's something you cannot buy and
you've pissed off people to the point
where now your rival your competitor is
getting that value that's bad I wouldn't
be surprised if we see Cora's stock
going up because of this so now the
question is
as we enter The Fray in terms of the
brand Civil War
how far does this go you know like I'm
saying if I'm gonna buy a bottled water
I'll just I'm going to order Trump water
can I order Trump water from now on
Trump's Trump you know Trump's got his
own bottled water brand for his Hotel
chain I'm just gonna order that and
we're gonna have in the basement you
could probably get it I'm gonna look it
up I'm gonna look it up well we need to
stand firm on this boycott because one
problem with the right is we always give
up our own power like why is it that
we're so quick to just end these
boycotts we don't hold these companies
accountable and then we're shocked when
we see the left continues to win and the
left continues to pull them over because
Whoopi said it herself they shouldn't be
scared of us they should be scared of
them that is very intentional and they
are winning because they'll actually try
to cancel a company they'll stop putting
their dollars towards something but
conservatives we always choose
convenience there's more infrastructure
on their side to just hold out and hold
through for us for a lot of companies
like this comes up a lot when we talk a
lot about the TV shows and stuff that we
review right because it's very easy to
say that you're not going to watch
anything from Disney or you're not going
to watch anything from these companies
or Netflix but at the end of the day if
part of your job requires you to add
actually end up reviewing their content
because it's still held in the public
you know and public eye is something to
talk about it's very hard to get away
from that and like you said to yourself
uh yes well I'm saying it's I I don't
I'm I'm not a boycotter in that respect
a lot of times I'll hold the product
accountable if I don't like the product
that's being made whether whether it's
movies or television I will call it out
for what it is when it's bad but for a
lot of those things I don't do the
boycott because I don't find that it's I
don't find it effective because these
companies seem to exist in a post-profit
era anyways it doesn't feel like no
matter how much we now you said they've
lost like what six million or six
billion it was six in value something
billions ten of billion dollars every
time that we talk about this with Disney
or something like that they fire a few
thousand workers and then next year
they're just right back where they were
before and I just I don't see it maybe
it just needs to be held at a stronger
pressure point for a longer period of
time but I do think that we overestimate
this is our
go ahead I'm gonna say this is this is
why it's like the most important culture
War battle it's too easy yeah it's too
easy it's too easy for me to be like hey
everybody
you want to help win the culture War buy
a different beer that's it you don't got
to stop drinking yeah you don't gotta go
to a different bar when you go to the
bar you sit down and say but no uh uh
what do we got the course and it's why
it's so important that companies like
daily wire and Eric D July are making
their own products obviously I'm talking
in a different medium here but making an
alternative to what you're being fed by
these companies is extremely important I
don't think Bud Light did this stunt for
Consumer profit though I think they're
just trying to raise their social credit
score essentially because these big
corporate investing firms they are all
about that the social credit score and
it's called I believe it's uh consumer
equality index or I forgot what the C is
Corporation and Quality Index and that's
like one of the most weighing factors in
the social credit score that these
companies have and that CEI it was
founded by the biggest LGBT lobbying
group in 2002 and so then Bud Light
would already is like a formerly
extremely pro-american group and a lot
of these people hate Americas probably
already seen as in the negative so they
have to like earn their way back forward
exactly yeah take a look at this it's
not just a boycott right now
Anheuser-Busch is accused of racist and
sexist hiring practices that prioritized
minorities in complaint filed by Trump
advisors Legal Group during the Dylan
Mulvaney firestorm
you know Anheuser-Busch could have just
stayed out of this whole thing
after they accidentally stepped in it
they could have just apologized they
didn't and now not only are they being
targeted by the view Whoopi Goldberg
they're now facing a lawsuit from
America First legal they say the group
claimed that companies are using the
cloak of equity to proudly discriminate
based on race color national origin and
sex in their Employment Practices AFL
who's President and America first
legal's president and CEO is a former
Trump advisor Stephen Miller
sent a complaint letter to the St Louis
Missouri office for the EEOC requesting
an investigation into anheuser-busch's
programs amazing look at this what is
this Brewing scholarship
developed in partnership with uncf the
annual scholarship program supports 25
black college students pursuing degrees
ranging from business to food science
that could lead to a career in the
Brewing industry so is is that what
they're being targeted like is these uh
scholarships
they say one is the leadership
accelerator program which advises which
advertises that it provides formal
mentorship executive interaction and
leadership development curriculum for
those who identify with historically
underrepresented groups as they join our
organization in a full-time capacity it
only encourages people of black Native
American and Latino Origins to apply
there you go this is not a regular
corporate program where the company
describes the role as focusing on hiring
the next generation of leaders within
the North American sustainability and
procurement Department in other words it
is a fast track program to Executive
leadership positions at Anheuser-Busch
and it is limited to candidates based on
race the pro forma equal opportunity
employer language at the end of the
posting does mask the company's
discriminatory intent and purpose
interesting now they're getting hit over
what basically tons of companies are
doing but good on the America First
legal I guess these diversity quotas are
nothing new and affirmative action
surely isn't new and when those were
created they weren't supposed to last
this long but now it's created what I
basically call Black privilege where we
are given all these opportunities just
because of the color of our skin and I
feel like it's such an outdated concept
that it shocks me that you still have
companies that are going so out of their
way to push for minorities as if
minorities can't be successful on our
own right it's honestly insulting to me
and I feel like it's going to continue
until I honestly feel like white people
are going to have their own version of
like a civil rights movement just
because these racist things just keep
happening in these companies I I think
it's going to result in heightened
racial tension people fighting and then
you've already seen people claiming to
be like white Rights Movement like stuff
like that's what I several years and
they're making these arguments like hey
you know a poor white dude who wants to
go to college shouldn't have barriers
placed in front of them in response to
me he just says you're a white
supremacist that is
so bad like all of it all of it and like
the idea of like having people start
having people start having white people
start saying we need a white
you know uh affinity group and and have
to have that kind of stuff for white
people that is a terrible idea it's a
horrible idea but if only because the
left is gonna say racist and everyone's
gonna believe it and you're gonna look
like absolute like straight up
cross-burning racists and it's very hard
to get rid of these programs because not
only do they get employees like like
Donald Glover got hired at NBC for cheap
because he was hired through like a
diversity Excellence program right and
it comes with great publicity because
half their jobs are just going to these
luncheons where they go to the you know
and they go Pat each other on the back
and they lead to articles that are
written in trade magazine so they get
all this good publicity on top of hiring
someone that's subsidized so it's very
hard to get rid of those programs
in regards to White rights and all that
stuff I think it's I I think it's a bad
idea for I I agree with you Phil but at
the same time
we're getting to a point where if you
want to get into certain universities
they're they're they're giving benefits
to People based on race and it's making
it harder for so so look at this way
they want at these universities what
they claim is called racial parity where
it's like okay so if the country's 13
black seven percent Asian you know
whatever that's what's going to be in
the schools but that's not what's
happening what's happening is they're
giving like 20 20
and so certain people of certain races
are getting boosted up certain rates are
getting pushed down Asians especially
are getting pushed down don't be
surprised then if you start seeing
groups of people who claim to be white
rights and they're not white
supremacists you like you there's a
distinction a white supremacist a person
who thinks that they're race is superior
versus a white rights person who's
making the argument that like hey I'm
I'm a lower income Carpenter my kid
wants to go to college and they're
saying he can't yeah and now you're
gonna get that those people making those
advocacy groups you know the D you were
talking about the default left this
morning today on one of the things that
default left is going to hear that and
they're going to think racist they're
not gonna matter I know but that's going
to make America worse it's going to make
people it's like yeah this is just to me
Domino's falling over yeah you're not so
you've already seen the Asian groups
coming out because of Harvard and
affirmative action stuff the SAT scores
for like the average agent has to be
like you have to score like 1300 because
they're like well there's too many Asian
people which is in my opinion insane if
you get if you pass pass
and so yeah you're gonna start seeing
more and more of these groups of people
maybe they'll try and mask it they'll
call it like Irish affiliation or
something like that but it's going to be
some kind of white rights thing yeah
you're gonna see lawsuits like this
they're going to be called white
supremacists but I will say
perhaps the reason we won't see those
groups forming is because Republicans
are too scared of the left so they won't
call it that they'll call it America
First legal you know where I'm not
arguing that America First legal is
fighting on behalf of white people I'm
saying they're going to give it names
like the the American Pride you know
rights organization there's the word
Patriot has been turned into something
that they find to be despicable they're
synonymous with racism they're trying to
do that with the Betsy Ross flag
absolutely
we'll try to who was it like with Colin
Capron who got that shoe yeah I think I
think it was yeah and it's like it was I
I know there were people I definitely
responded with a picture of Barack Obama
with the Betsy Ross flag behind him when
he was inaugurated it's like give me a
break founding Flex so ridiculous I mean
they still do the same thing with the
Gadsden flag and you have to explain to
them that it has nothing to do with that
that it was a revolutionary but they're
lying on purpose no yeah they're just
trying to trample over the things that
remind people of what this country was
founded upon the gazden flag is
individuality you know and and resisting
tyranny Liberty and things like that and
they want to turn Liberty into fascism
they they lie cheat and they steal
that's what they do and that's why they
win because they have no morals and
because they they have no problem with
breaking the rules if it means that
they're we were just talking about this
today okay they they have race swapped
uh or they've made a colorist move for
the casting the Lilo and Stitch it
sounds off but it tracks okay so the
they casted a woman who is uh not
Polynesian to play a character to play
lilo's mom in Lilo and Stitch right and
they don't care and the lady basically
makes the argument she says it's okay to
race swap Ariel in The Little Mermaid
because it benefits black people to now
have representation in this field but it
doesn't benefit a minority group if we
do it this way they literally just admit
it doesn't matter if we're being
hypocritical yes we're we're right
because our end goal is more righteous
that's the logic of it used that is the
logic of the left hand exactly yes yeah
I'm pretty sure that woman that got
Castle was actually Polynesian she's
just I think Polynesian and part white
so they were saying that she just wasn't
dark no no she's um she's um Filipino I
believe I don't believe she's Polynesian
but she's born in Hawaii so she's by all
for all intents and purposes that's why
they're not calling it racist they're
calling it colorist so it's different
it's about Shades not about actual
racial makeup so there's one thing that
I want to point out like people talk
about there's a lot of people talking
about critical race Theory and everyone
was saying oh blah blah I don't know
what it was and it's not this or
whatever
they're one of the things that that
critical race Theory talks about is
having a critical Consciousness awoken a
critical racial Consciousness when you
awaken a critical racial Consciousness
in white people they they essentially
are saying look you should feel bad
that's the whole uh the white fragility
but the book makes that argument there's
gonna be an amount of people that are
gonna be like well I don't feel bad you
know and they're going to be like well
okay so now I'm gonna have a white
affinity group and I'm going to join it
and I'm not going to feel bad and Jordan
Peterson made this argument you know six
seven years ago that like there's going
to be a cert if you focus on race all
the time which is the illiberal thing to
do the liberal thing to do the the
Enlightenment ideas is that the
individual matters if you focus on the
individual you'll be fine but if you
focus on Races then races are going to
start to do it more and more and it's it
ends up creating more and more
segregation in your in your Society it's
a terrible idea they hate focusing on
the individual yeah they do
I mean I feel like that's what they're
already doing because I always call
critical race Theory just critically
looking for racism into everything where
we're told as young children especially
as a young black kid you're told to look
at the differences between the purse or
you and the people next to you instead
of realizing like oh we have so much in
common we have all these different
cultural aspects that might be different
but they're cool we can learn about each
other's cultures instead we're told to
basically hate our neighbor hate the
person next to us if they're not the
same color as us I don't understand how
anybody can feel that that is productive
to put into the minds of kids and you
know it's not because these educators
are hiding it in curriculum they're
calling it all kind of other things
they're calling it ethnic studies or
sometimes they just call it something
that has nothing to do with CRT but
they're still putting it in the
curriculum well let me ask you about
your experience so your story is you're
a black lives matter activist cast onto
a reality show started doing your
research for the show and then debunked
yourself and now what you consider
yourself conservative I guess yeah I'd
say conservative I have some things I
lean libertarian on but overall it's a
conservative so how did this happen what
is this
so basically it was in 2020
um I was in the process for the show
already when everything happened with
George Floyd and then after that they
started wanting even more footage of
just the things that I was working on as
far as being a BLM activist because I
was doing it before it even blew up uh
so in that process I found a Candace
Owens video actually on accident and I
was so mad at what she said because she
said only in the black community do we
take our lowest common denominator and
make that the Forefront of our community
so I was so enraged by that because I
thought about it and I'm like she's
pretty much right so I started listing
out like different prageru videos I
found because she was working heavily
with prageru at the time and I just
tried to debunk everything I was leaning
towards being a socialist even at that
time too so with socialism with CRT with
cultural appropriation just one by one
I'm watching these five minute videos on
prageru.com or I'm watching Candace
Owens videos and I just realized wow
I've been lied to about everything my
entire perspective growing up black and
feeling like I had to root my identity
and my blackness was religious a sham
and it was taught to me for strategic
purposes it's what I look back at it as
so so what was what were some of the
stuffs you were working on as a BLM
activist like what were you doing
um so I was online advocating a lot like
I wasn't like a huge name as a BLM
activist but I was definitely helping
organize some local events I was always
posting on Instagram about oh like this
is racist this is what a microaggression
is like pretty much teaching people to
look at every single thing as racist and
when I look back at those old videos and
clips that I had I just cringe oh man
there's nothing the left organizes so
much better oh yeah yeah just infinitely
better but it was like it was mainstream
and popular so it was easy I'd imagine
right like you turn on the news and
they're telling you exactly what you
want to hear well 2020 it was it
definitely wasn't 2020 before that it
was still was people were leaning
towards my direction or they couldn't
tell me I was wrong because they still
even before George Floyd didn't want to
be called racist but at the time yeah I
hadn't I didn't have much pushback and I
would have conversations with
conservatives and people on the other
side of the aisle and it was interesting
that I didn't get the hatred that I now
received being on the other side like
being a conservative and try to have
these exact same conversations with
liberals they don't want to talk to me
or if they do talk to me it's such an
angry conversation that's so based in
emotion that it's so hard to get logic
into the conversation so you're watching
these Candace Owens video you mentioned
that uh
she made the argument that the black
community how did you find how did you
describe it uh yeah we take the lowest
common denominator and make that the
Forefront of our community you still see
that today look at people like cardi B
putting put on the pedestal that she's
on that's terrifying you have a stripper
who notoriously was struggling men and
robbing them and doing all these
different things and guess who decides
to interview her Joe Biden Joe Biden
wants to give her a platform because
that's how he feels that he can reach
the Black and Hispanic communities and
that's very telling on how the left
views people of color that he went and
got someone that was borderline
illiterate to be the person to convey
his different talking points I do think
it's fair to point out though
I I think everybody elevates the lowest
common denominator because it sells but
that being said I mean if you compare
cardi B and Joe Biden Joe Biden is
corrupt and crooked and represents like
the worst of American political
political class as is Hillary Clinton
and then here he is sitting with cardi B
I mean I think and there's I like Carter
you'd be more than Joe Biden I mean
hasn't she come out and said some stuff
that's actually fairly based she did
call out the Dalai Lama for the weird
stuff about yeah she did she did she did
say that that was weird so she's got
that going for her she's had a couple
different things and she like call out
inflation inflation she's like my
grocery bill has gone up by like 500
yeah I think she might just be like
I think the issue is not so much cardi B
but you're right in the elevation of
like what lowest common denominator
stuff or I should say Candace Owens was
right so when you heard that that pissed
you off because you didn't believe it or
what it did because then I started
thinking specifically about George Floyd
at the time and when you look at back at
his character and the kind of person he
was and even just the tragedy of what
happened to him when you look back at
all of that what about him was worth
putting him on murals putting him on all
these buildings when you drive through
these cities people have tattoos of
George Floyd there's probably going to
be streets named after him if there are
already it's creepy I'm from Minnesota
so I'm from that area right and it's
it's weird too because you think about
it I'm like if you get a tattoo of
somebody like that if you haven't at
least done a cursory look into like
their social media history like you are
owned by the media like if you if you're
going to get somebody tattooed on you or
you're going to evangelize someone to
that level right you should at the very
least have a general understanding you
could make the argument that look I'm
not tattooing him I'm tattooing what his
death represents you could make that
argument I still think it's a bad
argument it's weird but you should at
least look into what they're doing most
people aren't they just they don't
realize it and they're not looking any
deeper into it were you were you weren't
religious I'd imagine then were you I am
you were I always have been back then it
wasn't as like devout as it is now it's
definitely grown in the last couple
years you start to learn stuff yeah I
only asked because there was that mural
of George Floyd on the wall that got
struck by lightning and it was just the
George Floyd part and I'm just like dude
that I don't know man that's so good I
don't know I don't know if I don't I I'm
not gonna prescribe good bad or whatever
it just happened like I I I I just love
getting an opportunity to talk about
this happening there was a building they
painted this big mirror on the whole
wall right in the middle was George
Floyd and for some reason lightning
struck the wall and blew up the brick
portion with just George Floyd on it and
I'm just I'm just Freedom people have to
stop playing with God God's not here to
play that's crazy I mean fall Idols or
whatever you want to call it but I mean
to the point where people are tattooing
George Floyd on themselves and yeah look
man it's like we can we can lament
criminal justice and degradation of
culture we can lament this dude was
doing was chewing on a speed ball or
whatever we can we can say It's
upsetting that he died and all that
stuff but to the point where people put
tattoos on their body of this guy they
build statues for him that's insane
I mean that's just crazy yeah but people
have done the same thing with Trayvon
Martin oh and all that stuff so that's
not going anywhere it's kind of what
happens when the media becomes yeah well
not that but the the media turns real
life people in real life tragedy into
celebrity because you don't know where
your television ends and where the
actual news story begins so real life
people who have gone through real life
experiences whether good or bad are now
the idols of certain people especially
people that are very very aware of
what's going on in the news or think
they are I still don't think Trayvon
Martin was the best comparison to George
Floyd though even though it's all under
that BLM umbrella like there were
similarities
yeah of course
um back in 2008 I believe
um uh well it was later than that 12 12
13 2014 I thought well 12. yeah that was
okay yeah I think it was 20 I think it
was like 2013 or something I'm not sure
about Trayvon but I know Mike Brown was
2012. if I'm no no no Mike Brown was
2014 I'm pretty sure
yeah but George Zimmerman the person who
killed Trayvon Martin didn't have any
type of
I guess just need to protect Society I
still feel like he's a pretty terrible
person George Zimmerman himself has a
really bad track record so I don't think
it's as comparable
um with like uh Derek Chauvin Michael
Brown would have been the better example
of the one yeah yeah that's yeah that's
that's the better example that I'm
thinking but those those people those
real life people have now been turned
into a form of celebrity that people
worship in whether you actually look
into it you have to do a lot of research
if you're actually going to look into
something like that well let me ask you
so you're you're this activist your
borderline socialist you start what
they're gonna have you on TV you start
watching these videos I imagine you you
quit the show or you didn't go to and be
like hey I got some things to say on
this show you know it was tough time
like I was mortified like everybody when
I tell the story now they just viewed
just like all the positive of it but you
have to think this is months of just
turmoil of all these different things
that I believed in for so long being
exposed is just not legitimate but it
got to October and I was getting ready
to fly to London and I just had this
pow-wow with myself and like I can't do
this I don't stand for any of this
anymore so I called them and I just
pretty much told them it just wasn't for
me what are your friends and family
think
uh I didn't tell too many people I was
in the process actually because they
were pretty strict on the ndas
no I mean like uh when you started
discovering that a lot of the stuff you
thought was not true I imagine like you
go to your friend and you're like
I I have to imagine because I I've been
there where
I'm hanging out at my friend's house I'm
in California and they said they're like
hanging around like drinking coffee and
then one of them just says something
completely false and then it's like the
first thing I think is like oh what do I
do if I come you can't just come out and
be like you're wrong you know what I
mean they're not going to take well to
that they want to be an authority on
this political ideology that's why they
brought it up
yeah it was definitely interesting I had
a combination of everything a lot of my
friends kind of started to make the
journey with me becoming more
conservatives because they knew how
passionate I was about BLM and all the
liberalism I stood for so for me to look
at it and be like I don't know about
this anymore especially with everything
happening with covid and everyone's
trust in every institution starting to
be questioned a lot of people started to
just support me regardless of what it
was that I stood for on the other hand I
had people completely excommunicate me
including family members I have a
sibling I haven't spoken to in years wow
that come just deleted me off of
everything hasn't spoken to me and I
have friends who have done the same
thing but I don't even view them as real
friends I don't I don't believe that
actions like that are related to like I
think that's evidence to the fact they
know you're right they to a certain
degree that you're right they're driven
by social acceptance not by Factor logic
and so they're like you threaten their
attempts to fit in so they have to
remove you because we don't do that like
the right tends not to do that I say
tends not to because you know it's not
absolute but the the libertarian former
liberal types the conservative types are
constantly trying to tell people like
here's what I think and why and the left
is just more like I don't want you to
say what you think you shouldn't be
allowed yeah I'd say that's really
really prominent in the black community
uh the black community has a tendency to
put each other in a box and if the
second you step out of that box or as
Candace Owen says escaping the
Democratic Plantation it's a huge issue
just as far as the music you're allowed
to like the clothes you're supposed to
wear the culture the way you talk the
way that if you speak too eloquently
you're insulted in a lot of areas in the
black community we're even told like I
remember being a kid I'm in this area
full of Agriculture and I was bullied by
my family because I was going to take an
FFA class they talked me out of doing it
they're like you're black you can't be
in an agriculture class which is so
wrong to begin with for so many reasons
but black people tend to put the
shackles on our own feet and I keep
telling people within the community and
outside the community that you have to
stop allowing yourself to be forced into
a category you have to be able to look
at the bigger picture of the world and
just identify who you actually are
rather than be told who you are because
you're a skin color man
so you made it though huh Prager you
hired you I made it he's been good to me
and that takes a lot of Courage though
like to to walk away from a support
system like that in a lot of ways those
are the people that are structurally the
most supportive to your upbringing in a
lot of ways right like it's got to be
very very difficult to walk away from
people that have been that instrumental
in getting to you you know being a part
of your life up until that point yeah I
just have to change my mentality I
didn't walk away from them they walked
away from me no since I guess so you
have to you have to accept when they're
going to walk away from you yeah of
course uh it's just one of those things
I realize that if I'm not willing to
stand on truth and integrity then what
is it that I actually represent because
if you don't stand for anything you fall
for everything right and I just want to
be able to look myself in the mirror if
I continue to advocate for these things
just because I'm told to rather than
recognizing the research that I've done
and going out and being like you know
what this is actually the truth I was
wrong so many people are afraid just to
get online and admit that they're wrong
or even just person to person but
humility is one of the greatest things
that you can possibly have and the media
likes to shame doing your own and
research now you're not supposed to do
your own research anymore you're very
dangerous that's crazy it's very
dangerous we had a Winston Marshall from
Mumford and Sons on that last week and
he so his story is he reads books and he
had like no followers but I mean Mumford
and Sons is a huge band no joke look at
their discography it's like their first
album hit number two billboard then
every other album was number one when it
released they were huge and so he tweets
out like just read Andy knows book very
great good work Andy no and they
attacked him for it he basically is
forced to issue an apology and then I
mean this dude's amazing shout out to to
this guy he's there's a reason why his
he was part of a band that Rose to the
top he said he didn't want to live the
LIE he couldn't live with himself
knowing that he put this fake apology he
thought to himself what am I going to do
go to all my friends and family and say
I don't I I I believe this thing I don't
actually believe I can't do it so I so
he was like he decided you know what
fine to preserve to save his band mates
from this this Trauma from this or from
this Scandal and controversy in crisis
he's going to leave the band and then
he's going to come out publicly retract
his apology and say here's what I really
think so they went after him he thought
about and said
nah he would rather be true to himself
with all of the anger and hate around
him than to live a lie I I imagine
that's it felt like kind of what you
were conveying to yeah for sure I have
so much respect for that and I always
tell people like to an extent you have
to prioritize your piece so if you are
not willing to be outspoken about
everything that you believe in at least
be willing to stand firm and stand
against the things that you don't
believe in yeah like especially with
things like when you're seeing all the
kids going to drag shows you don't have
to necessarily go out and just say like
everything about your conservative
values but you at least have to look at
something as foul as little children
being at a drag show and being able to
say you know what we need to stop this
there has to be some level of pushback
but it isn't I mean I have to imagine
that there I'll put it this way there's
tropes about the the black community
actually being fairly conservative right
oh yeah not like they the left would
call it homophobic call whatever you
want so I have to imagine this stuff
doesn't go over well
oh it doesn't it doesn't at all I've
been saying that for so long a lot of
black people now and this goes for
pretty much every ethnicity especially
his uh Hispanic and Asian communities
where there are so many conservative
values that are just instilled in these
minority groups as families but they
still continue to vote Democratic
because they're told to because if you
ask so many of these people in these
communities why is it that you vote with
democratics like that's what I was told
to do as a kid yeah that's what my whole
family does I mean I was sold too I I
remember going with my family and I'm
told like so what just Democrat all the
way down I'm like okay I guess they have
done such a amazing job of branding the
right as inherently racist but not just
that as somehow the party of money even
though all evidence points to the
contrary now that big business votes uh
goes to the left now all of the
corporations are behind leftist values
but when you read these articles from
these Outlets they talk about the right
being the party of of uh money and
privilege and all the evidence points to
the contrary but it doesn't matter
because like you said a lot of them
aren't going to do the research
necessary to actually go out and figure
that out have you have you had a chance
to talk with Candace Owens about all
this briefly I met her once it was like
a really quick passing by but we've
messed each other a few times she's been
super supportive me yeah I imagine that
would be one heck of a conversation to
be honest oh yeah I can't wait to the
time I get to just sit down and really
pick her brain on things what's funny
about what you said about trying to
debunk the prageru five minute videos
those would be the hardest ones to
debunk because it's literally a lot of
them are just listed facts about it
would be like impossible to go through
that you have to literally if they were
lying they'd be the like the most lies
you've ever seen in a row because most
of them are just those are like a lot of
my favorite videos that they did back
well I I recently just did uh I did two
Prager u5 and I think I don't know if
they're both out yet maybe one of them
but it was like specific references to
things that happened and like the the
summary of the video is based on like
here's the thing that happened here's
the media said here's what the
government responded with I think we
talked about Mike Brown Michael Brown
and how the activist said hands up don't
shoot but then Obama's justice
department said actually that's not true
so it's Whose Line Obama or the activist
Eric Holder the AG and Obama was the
president they investigated and found
that it that Michael Brown was not did
not have his hands up so I mean it's
clear that it was not uh uh that Michael
Brandon Michael Brown did not have his
hands up that was alive from what's day
one let's talk about what's going on in
Chicago
we got the story from Fox News teen
takeover terrorizes Chicago as hundreds
of teenagers destroy property and attack
tourists so Saturday so I mean weekend I
mean look I'd love to to go in on that
joke with you my friend but no no
I just this is nuts so I think that's a
mess of hundreds to thousands of
teenagers romping through the city
jumping on cars setting vehicles on fire
smashing Windows just today it was
reported they tried breaking into the
Art Institute it's only April too and
it's only April I mean Summer's gonna
get gonna get wild yeah and it's
happening in LA but so I don't know in
the Art Institute I have to imagine has
probably got billions of dollars worth
of Art in there and if they got in it
would have been like history being
ransacked apparently I don't know how it
went down but they're trying to break in
and two two of the teens got shot
gunshots ring out everyone's scatters
there's no reason this is not a protest
they're not pissed off about anything
this is just societal and cultural
breakdown of people rampaging through
the cities there's these videos I can't
even play these videos for you on
YouTube that's how crazy it is there's
there's videos there's a woman standing
in a doorway at a building doing nothing
they run up grab her and just start
mercilessly beating her for no reason yo
it's getting crazy
see people cut like you could see people
just hooking no reason right no yeah new
mayor in charge yet I don't think he's
in charge not in charge yet right but
I'm pretty sure he did come out and he
said it's not constructive to vilify the
group of Rowdy teams that torched cars
in Rampage organized on social media
what though
I mean it's horrifying to see what's
happening in it's it's happening in La
too it's probably coming to a city near
you but uh I gotta be honest I mean I'm
happy for the people of Chicago I'm I'm
very happy I mean that woman I I don't
know her personally but there's a very
strong possibility she voted for this
you
look so so I'll put it this way like no
nobody should be attacked it shouldn't
happen and this lady is an individual I
don't blame her for any of this but as a
body of citizens Chicago has been under
Democrat control for over a hundred
years and this all of this stuff so you
made the joke another Saturday yeah
because of the perception of what
Chicago is having grown up there I've
certainly seen similar things to this
but never this bad and at this point now
I'm like I'm not surprised this is the
traject the trajectory of the city you
keep voting for this stuff over and over
again don't be surprised the new
mayor-elect says don't demonize them
it's not constructive
I don't understand how anybody could be
shocked that this is happening in
Chicago I mean there's already a culture
that looting and writing has no
consequences there hasn't been
accountability in that City in a very
long time you can even see what the
mayor-elect is saying doesn't take
accountability and the other part of his
statement I read that he was saying
something along the lines of how you
can't blame these kids because this is a
city that doesn't have enough
opportunities for them it is the left's
fault that there's not opportunity there
because why would any company want to be
located in Chicago where they're going
to have their buildings burned down
they're going to be robbed there's going
to be shootings every day they're losing
money but then you're upset when they
leave Chicago even though you've done
nothing to protect them you're always
demonizing them you're always saying
that they need to pay more in taxes you
have not made the city of Chicago a
place that any business would want to be
or a place that any business could
survive and now you're shocked that the
kids there quote unquote don't have
enough opportunity this thing on purpose
and this was happening during uh 2020
riots in Minnesota right businesses
would get looted and shut down or bricks
through the window and then stores that
people need to go to to be able to get
supplies things that actually matter you
know whether it's groceries things like
that you know baby formula and then
nobody can get to them for days at a
time while they're either repairing
what's going on there or they're just
simply waiting out the riots to end and
nobody it doesn't ever click in their
brain that in a lot of ways when you
live in the city I wasn't even living in
Minneapolis at the time I was in the
outskirts I was in West Saint Paul and
this stuff was still happening and you
understand that this is going to keep
happening unless you learn to vote in
people who are willing to put into place
different policies or at the very least
keep them in jail and not just let them
out on bail right away that's what
they're doing and if you look back at
the old videos of the Looting and
rioting that happens look very closely
at those videos you will be hard-pressed
to find someone stealing eggs or a pack
of chicken or something that they need
to put food on the table or even
blankets for their kids to stay warm no
they're selling TVs they're selling air
pods they're are stealing all these
things that they don't need and saying
it's in the name of reparations but
they're not doing this for anything
productive it's just complete
selfishness with no accountability
remember when AOC said they're looting
because they need bread yeah yeah and
everyone's like have you seen a video of
them looting dude they're stealing shoes
now you can argue they need shoes yeah
but like they're still good shoes and
the counters are still full of bread
nobody even took it did you see that's
the bread did you see the video of the
lady trying who asked for the thousand
dollars and said this is my Rosa Parks
moment at the Target
what okay
um did you see this no okay so this lady
basically says like she wants to get her
stuff for free and starts like harassing
the lady who works at the Target or
whatever and the security guard she
starts yelling The Secret Garden backs
the security guard up into his office
and the dude just knocks her out wow and
then she got arrested because she got in
everyone's face and got and got physical
this is where we're going man she called
it her Rosa Parks moment into the
groceries for reparations for I I feel
like all of these policies put forth by
democrats are actually intended to harm
Democrats and then you get these
Democrat voters being like for some
reason Republicans keep voting against
their own interests and it's like dude
the the social welfare policies are
actually ruining the economic standards
ruining families making things worse
they want you to sterilize and abort
your kids I don't think they like you
very much I think their policies are
intent on making your life worse and you
look at what's going on in Chicago and
when this guy said when this mayor like
says don't this is Brandon Johnson don't
demonize these teenage boys too 16 17
were shot and he's like well you know
they it's almost like they want this
stuff to happen bad things to all the
people of the city but you know what man
I can't be mad about it because they
voted for it so it's like if you're a
conservative or a moderate and you live
in Chicago
I guess at this point I'm like I'm sorry
that this is happening to you I guess
but like you're choosing to live in a
city where all of this stuff is going
down and I know people always say oh but
it's like you don't understand I don't
have the money I can't move it's too
hard
the example that I give is
if your house was on fire you wouldn't
stop and think well I could leave but I
have nowhere else to go no you run out
the door you stand barefoot outside
thinking what do I do now so these
people were saying like I can't get out
of Chicago all you're really telling me
is the fire hasn't reached your house
yet
you can't convince me that the left is
not a death cult because everything that
they stand for both legislatively and
ideologically just relate to the demise
of society whether it's obesity whether
it's how hard they push for abortion
whether it's allowing all these crimes
and murders to happen in the cities
everything that you look at with them
leads to depopulation or it leads to
just less people happening even
everything with same-sex is like they
don't even want these heterosexual
couples to be able to have kids they're
wanting to sterilize kids with the Trans
stuff everything that the left does
leads to death has anybody else noticed
that yeah and that's why I was saying
like I don't think they like you very
much like you go to your politician and
the the Republican guy says hey man you
should have more kids it's like okay
he's basically telling you to survive he
likes you there should be more of you
these Democrats go you have you
considered aborting that baby and it's
like that's something you would say to
someone you don't like like you go to
you if there's a like these two women
right imagine there's two men and one
one woman is pregnant and they hate each
other's guts yeah one woman the the one
woman's gonna go and be like abort your
kid like that's not a nice thing to say
to somebody they'll probably call
themselves humanists as well yes they'll
say they'll say we are secular humanists
and they'll tell you that they believe
that they want good things for the human
race but they want fewer humans it's not
that they dislike you it's that they
like the planet more therefore they want
the planet to survive because humans
according to them are basically a blight
it is dude look at this look at this
video look at this video this is this is
Compton California gas station and these
Street takeovers have been happening all
over the city where people are just
smashing their way in just that's it
welcome to life in uh Los Angeles and
this is similar to Chicago the crazy
thing is there's like this video of one
dude just like smacking a bunch of
condoms off a shelf into the air and
it's like he's not looting dude it's
it's not even ransacking it's just it's
Rampage and all and it all it takes is
one person that decides they want to be
violent like they could be all looters
except for one dude that's just like all
right I'm gonna go in there and I'm
gonna break the guy you know the person
working behind the the counter's face
open and those type of agitators end up
at those types of absolutely absolutely
because they get the opportunity it's
like people talk about
um people talk about you know the church
when priests that are molesting kids or
whether it's schools and stuff the thing
is they go where the access is the
Predators go with the accesses so
predators are gonna go to where people
are rioting so that way if they want to
be violent for no reason they're going
to go to where the riots are this is the
story from Ferguson when I was on the
ground and uh the the hardcore fans of
Tim cast have heard me tell the story a
billion times so bear with us for those
that didn't hear it uh simple version is
a bunch of young black men linked arms
to protect the liquor store that Michael
Brown had stolen the cigarillos from and
when they were interviewed by a guy from
Al Jazeera he's like why are you
protecting the store they said the
people who are looting and burning down
these stores don't live here our
community is being destroyed right now
I remember watching across the street a
bunch of people ran and smashed Windows
started stealing stuff from a bunch of
stores and the locals who lived there
were begging for help to stop the
rioting
but people from other other
neighborhoods said now's our chance and
came in and started stealing and
destroying things and then leftists
wrote a wrote an article a leftist wrote
an article saying in defense of looting
and all of these white liberals come out
and said the reason that they're rioting
and looting in their own neighborhood is
because they're resisting the
bourgeoisie and the elites and I'm like
bro I was there the people who lived
there were begging for help to stop the
Looting of their neighborhood like
nobody wants their gas station burned
down nobody wants their local food court
burned down it's the people who don't
live there who are stealing everything
they can and then fleeing and the left
was coming in and cheering for it and
people who don't live there making
excuses for the people that are coming
into town stealing I gotta say I really
do think that a lot of these liberal
leftist types are actually overtly white
supremacists and just pretending not to
be because think about what they've done
remember that video where the two white
women are vandalizing property in a
black neighborhood and the two black
girls are like stop destroying our
neighborhood and like don't worry we're
doing it for you like come on if take
the context out of this and say just go
up to any leftist any even when you're
liberal friends not leftists but like a
liberal friend say if you saw two white
people destroying a black neighbor what
would you think
because I'll tell you what a
conservative would think like oh antifa
again huh because we get it because
people on the right people libertarian I
don't mean to imply I'm concerned I'm
saying people who are post-liberal who
are libertarian Freedom facts like to
call it have been paying attention to
the news and see this incessant white
liberal rampaging in black neighborhoods
that happened especially in 2020 and
then they come out and they say we're
here to support you and then they burn
down your your grocery store yeah sorry
I don't I don't I don't believe you I
think you might just be a white
supremacist in the classical sense they
destroy your neighborhood and they run
off businesses but they're here to help
guys when they write a book called in
defense of looting I think I think it's
a book now yeah it is I'm like I gotta
think that you're actually just a white
supremacist who wants to go and ruin the
you know they talk about uh the bombing
of Black Wall Street you're familiar
with this was it Tulsa I think it was I
believe so and and what am I supposed to
think about what they're doing when you
see two white women destroying black
businesses and they say don't worry
doing it for you I'm kind of like I
don't know it feels a whole lot like
that you know what Democrats have always
done you know I just don't believe you
and here we are today this is what they
do they claim they fight for you but
they actively harm you not that
Republicans are doing a whole lot for
Republicans mind you but still one of
the weirdest things back when I was in
the BLM culture and at some of these
protests I would say and to be clear I
never looted and I never write it I
always thought that was insane but I
would try to point out some of the
things that were really weird to me like
when I would watch the Looting happening
I would watch it on Twitch and I would
see why I'm assuming antifa members
breaking into these buildings in these
predominantly black neighborhoods and I
would ask myself I'm like why are white
people going in and destroying these
black owned businesses and then saying
that it's for racial Justice I didn't
understand it but when I would bring
those type things up at the rallies out
people would turn to me and be like Oh
either you're all in or you're all out
like I would just be shut down like it
was not a conversation when I would
bring up like there's so many white
people here it's like how many of them
are stealing and saying it's in the name
of reparations it was the weirdest thing
to me that nobody was willing to
actually point out all the black
communities being destroyed yeah is part
of that just because they feel like they
need to organize and they need to do
something therefore if they're not
allowed to criticize it they just have
to accept it for them well I think part
I think that's definitely a big part of
it and I think part of it was they knew
that their what they were fighting for
wasn't as concrete as they wanted it to
be so the second you start poking any
holes into BLM and that entire narrative
that the woke left had and still has
things start to crumble apart so they
don't want any holes poked in it at all
it's you have to believe in every single
thing that they say or you're kicked out
of the cold
and they shut you down if you do try to
speak about it anyways absolutely yeah I
mean you see that um
currently there's a kerfuffle on the
left about uh Anna kasparian she made
some remarks about her disliking uh
birthing people she doesn't want to be
called a birthing person yeah I think
that was the first or a person with a
womb shocking I caught a stream
uh sitch and Adam were doing a stream
talk they were covering a bunch of left
left-leaning people uh some people from
the Surfs and Matt Bender was on there
and they were they were just tearing her
down like just saying she's not allowed
to say this like really making it clear
that it was unacceptable that she had
stepped out of line and hadn't had
expressed a dissenting opinion it just
absolutely a guess and they went on and
on and apparently there was two
different streams where these five or
six people were going at her so I it's
not a surprise to hear that at all
um you know and it's something that I
think that the left has a significant
problem with the fact that you can't
have a descending opinion we're gonna
have one of those guys uh on the show I
think not this week maybe maybe in a
week or two a big big Lefty Twitter
personality interesting one of the
reasons that is too is because the media
tends to Parrot their beliefs right back
at them because they believe the same
thing that the media believes so they're
never challenged on a daily basis if you
are Center rights or libertarian your
views are constantly challenged by the
media you take in you know if you're
taking in any type of mainstream media
you're having your Viewpoint challenge
you might think they're wrong and most
of the time they are but you're at least
being given opposing viewpoints on a
regular basis and if you don't if you're
not used to hearing that that's a lot of
times shocking and that's where the
emotional responses tend to come in
yep
[Laughter]
Let's uh let's I was waiting to jump to
this story so this one is uh this is a
sad tale a sad tale from our good friend
Hank Green now if you don't know Hank
Green he's one of the OG YouTubers
and uh he tweeted this which universe is
the better one one with humans one
without humans well I voted for the one
with humans because I'm human and I live
here
but uh 41.1 percent said one without
humans he responded
I keep trying to do other versions of
this poll thinking that there's
something wrong with the question but it
I but it really does seem like 40
percent of you think humans shouldn't
exist and I find that so deeply outside
of my perspective that I need to do a
lot of thinking
he then added uh a little bit later I
feel like if an AI was like quote I'm 40
sure the universe without humans would
be better we'd be pretty worried
here's the funny thing these people
don't get it people like Hank Green he's
a default liberal he's surrounded by
default liberals and leftists they hate
human beings So you you're just
mentioning it earlier that it seems like
uh you know a lot of their policies are
actually just to harm you
and I was mentioning something similar
yeah if you've got here's the easiest
way to explain it
Hank Green's audience probably swinging
much more left he's like a VidCon guy
he's a major mainstream personality with
you know so liberals probably follow him
80 90 percent
if you're a Democrat politician and you
see a poll like this you know what that
means you're going to cater to the
people who don't like human beings so
you're out there campaigning and you're
like look
half of these people are really
concerned about their right to abortion
because they have a lot of loose sex a
lot of men and they want to be able to
get abortions if they get pregnant fine
the other half just don't want humans to
be alive anymore same solution to both
problems certainly then the Democrats
are going to advocate for that
it's a lot of the same people who have
been consuming a lot of nihilistic
propaganda on social media for years
about climate change every type of human
invention that's ever been created uh is
destroying the environment everything
we've ever done and succeeded is in some
way been reframed as a negative for The
Human Experience and I actually what you
were talking about earlier about social
media and how they will sometimes mess
with the algorithm I get that on Sundays
I sort it on Instagram Sundays become
the most nihilistic place ever on
Instagram it's nothing but the world is
going to end in 10 years manufacturing
is destroying the world and it's all and
they consume that content all the time
and they've been led to believe that
this type of hatred of humanity isn't
just good but something to be valorized
and you know what they do they complain
about how there's like a great
Extinction phase happening and how
humans are the human actions are killing
off all of these different forms of life
but they never stop to talk about the
the strange scientific experiments we're
doing to bring life back like trying to
clone a woolly mamas or calling ancient
viruses out of the ice sheets and
resurrecting them great ideas these are
all great ideas that humans are humans
are doing actually when people saw that
stuff during covert they're like maybe
you shouldn't maybe you should just not
bring stuff out of the ice caps until we
know for sure it's gonna hurt but but uh
simply put it really does feel like you
know everyone's always trying to figure
out what the Divide is like I've seen
people say it's nationalist versus
globalist and it's like as a component
of that and I think it's algorithmic
cult versus independent thought but
there is a component of humans are good
and humans are bad there's a component
of you know God God is real and there is
no God and if you're a nihilist and you
think nothing matters there's no
morality and everything is subjective
why would you want humans to be around
at all it's like uh Dr Manhattan in
Watchmen when he was like on Mars and
he's like would any of this be made
better by humans and the answer is yes
it would be I mean at least from a human
perspective because that's what we are
and that's what we strive for the
feelings and experiences of Being Human
I mean I don't know I was watching this
little bird building nest the other day
and I'm like I wonder what bird Society
must be like do you think they're like
you know life is good life is bad you
get depressed
I think a lot of this for a lot of the
best way to describe this for me the
best experience that I've had knowing
that people are very nihilistic right
now is when we had sunshine in like uh
January or February it was like really
nice out and people like well it's
because of climate change but we might
as well enjoy it while we're here yeah I
mean it didn't snow uh no we got like
none this year none and I was talking to
some old guy and he's like that's the
first night he's like 60 years old he's
like it's the first time in my life I
didn't get any snow yeah and I'm like oh
that's kind of crazy but of course
the issue is not so much about whether
or not there's snow it's about whether
or not humans are the direct impact and
so you know what I see are causing the
the crisis what I see with the left is
like
one without humans
what would this planet be without humans
it would just be a moist a moist ball of
rust some kind of exotic rust on it
oxidization process and you know these
people that vote to say that the world
would be better without humans are the
exact same people with the exact same
mentality about America they live in
America as if they have to be and then
they're so anti-American they're always
saying that they want to see the
downfall of America but where is better
yeah why is it that you see they never
actually give you an answer not usually
no it's parts of it's parts of places
that exist they wanted they want us like
an A La Carte Society where they can say
this is good in this place this is good
in this place this is good in this place
so let's take all these things and bring
them here and they imagine that they can
just manufacture the society if they
just say well these are the things that
we want we'll just bring them here and
and and act it's as if the people that
are involved don't matter at all and it
it's the the blank slate applied to
societies like societies have cultures
how societies have history so societies
have different values from one Society
to another so you can't just replicate
the the good things about one Society in
your Society without it without having
some kind of negative consequences or or
unforeseen consequences at least so
I think that it's a lot of a lot of the
idea that it it is as simple as just
well that works over there so how come
it doesn't work over here it was the
same mistake that we made when we went
to Iraq the idea that we could just
Implement democracy in in Iraq like oh
just get rid of the get rid of the
strong arm guy and and we'll make a
democracy and it'll work fine and that's
not the way that people work the cia's
been doing that for years
democracy all over the place I'm working
awesome
it's also the but a lot of Americans
what I've noticed and this was long
before I became politically aware hate
this like seem to have a if not a hatred
of this country they're embarrassed to
be from here and I never understood it
it's really simple is the glass half
full or is the glass half empty you know
are you are you excited that there is
water in your water bottle or are you
like angry because it's half gone the
glass is racist I'm just right that I
can drink the water here but this is
this is this is like I guess the thing
maybe like the real divide may be
optimism versus pessimism if you look at
the history of the United States you can
look at it a bunch of different ways you
can be honest and say there's a lot of
really awful stuff and a lot of really
good stuff or uh you can be angry and
just say this country is bad no matter
what it's all bad period it's born of
bad it's bad it's bad that's stupid and
that's depressive so I these people are
nihilistic half of them probably just
want to burn everything down because
they hate humans the other half refuse
to seek out the good because there's
something wrong with them I guess you
know I look back at American history and
if someone comes to me and says do you
know what the Americans did to the
Native Americans and you know in this
place in that place and I'll be like oh
yeah I write about that that's awful I
can't believe they would do that and
then it's like do you also know about
the good things this country has done
over the past several hundred years as
we've dramatically improved upon all of
those things and got to the point where
you have now been educated in publicly
funded institutions explaining we think
those are bad things yeah think about
the the college student who's like
America is awful and racist I learned
that at a publicly funded University the
government's paying you so you can learn
about how we don't like those things
anymore and they still think this
country is a problem
I think the end result is just
the left will cease to exist you know
they try to indoctrinate your kids the
only thing they can do but it's not
gonna it's not working uh and then the
right is going to just have a bunch of
babies and then 20 years you know there
we go you don't think it's working
what like the education stuff I'm saying
that you don't think that the
indoctrination from the left is working
in my eyes you don't think so uh why
like so for one shows like this we
consistently have like the highest live
viewer count on YouTube which is a good
sign you can see like the Budweiser
backlash The View being desperate
obviously there is let us indoct
urination it is very strong but I'm
speaking specifically in refer referring
to kids it is in my opinion not working
okay so uh simply put when parents
realize what's happening at their
schools start pulling their kids out
when there is now a national
conversation around school choice and
getting kids out of public schools and
moving away from these places it didn't
work and what I mean ultimately is
I think conservatives are gonna have
more kids
those kids are more likely to be
conservative they're they're going to
learn from their parents the parents are
waking up not all of them but many of
them are waking up to what's going on in
schools the left is beginning to fail
with places like Florida and other
states reforming these laws and banning
the stuff it may lead to
hyperpolarization but ultimately if
you're advocating if there if there were
two countries
and they were at odds with each other
and on one side they were saying have
more babies have more babies discipline
yourself strengthen yourself Eat Right
exercise and the other country was
saying be as fat as you want abort your
children and sterilize them would there
be any question to which country would
cease to exist in 20 years none
whatsoever so just because we are the
United States doesn't mean to me that
there is a mesh here clearly the
hyperpolarization is so pronounced that
the left and the right are are at such
fundamental odds that they may as well
be two different countries the point
where people are advocating for National
divorce and then what do you see
give it a long enough over long enough
period of time math is just math people
who don't have kids tend not to exist in
several Generations people who have kids
tend to pass on their ideas then you got
to get those kids out of call out of our
state-run colleges because I think we
can raise all the conservative kids we
want but if we send them to Public
Schools where they will later be
indoctrinated further into those
ideologies I don't know if it matters I
think you have to start at the
elementary you know at the school level
and then all the way up to colleges you
have to reform and not allow those kids
to be constantly flooded with the same
type of propaganda that we're seeing now
but I but I think we're we're moving in
that direction I think the left I I
everybody likes to talk about
um I shouldn't say everybody but they're
prominent individuals talking about
universities and the leftist ideology
and how it spread and all that but it
was never that strong until 2011 2012. I
think it's when social media algorithms
it was 2008 it was never that strong in
the U.S until so well not around the
world social media algorithms made every
country on the planet basically see this
massive spike in these conversations
however I think that was bad for them I
think if they had maintained the quiet
Edge and slow rolled this ideology over
a long period of time they'd have won
instead the algorithms slapped everybody
in the face with the most insane
versions of these ideologies that now
people are pushing back on it
universities are starting to get heat
because of it and people are
hyperpolarizing yeah I agree with that I
think for a while the left was starting
to win with their indoctrination but the
pendulum is starting to shift back over
to the right because what's happening is
the left continues to get more radical
they're going further and further right
while the right is just sitting left
left sorry yeah the left is getting
further and further left and the right
is just sitting there just trying to be
sane and I always tell people if you
want to help influence people to do more
research or to maybe reconsider their
mentality you don't even have to go deep
into like policies and politics just
talk about the cult culture like have
you seen the things with these naked
education shows or yeah there's all
these shows where they're getting naked
in front of children there is no sane
person in existence that's going to look
at that and not think that it's foul so
when you present that and you're like
well guess which side supports this and
it's all for this they start to question
their own let me spread around as much
as possible as many parents to see that
kind of stuff as possible I want to pull
up this tweet here we got this from
Scott Galloway he said Republicans uh of
one-fourth Republicans think all drag
shows should be banned living in another
Century question mark are you referring
to yourself sir I don't know what or
another dimension I am not surprised
that there are a court of Republicans
saying no drag shows that surprises me
in no way I don't what is it referring
to the 90s or something what other
Century but let me show you how crazy
this poll is so here's what it says who
should be allowed to attend drag shows
the purple says they should be allowed
for everyone the blue is restricted to
people 18 and older and there's not sure
and then for orange they should be
banned among all U.S adult citizens 25
say children should be allowed to attend
fifty percent say 18 and up only 12 are
not sure and 14 say ban it all
now among Democrats around 40 percent of
Democrats think children should be
allowed to attend sex shows
that's what it is drag is basically LGBT
burlesque you wouldn't put a kid you
wouldn't bring kid to a go-go dancer
Club you wouldn't bring your kid to a
burlesque show that's what they're
saying however 40 percent of Democrats
because 39 whose HB should have kids
four percent Democrats say 18 and up
only this is the popular position yeah
in fact eight percent of Democrats want
it banned for everyone okay let me
stress that again eight percent of
Democrats are like no drag shows allowed
for anyone who are those Democrats I
gotta ask you I was gonna say like where
are they that's like a magical unicorn
of a person I guess what like Old Blue
Dog Democrats that still believe in gun
rights and then you have among
Independents it reflects basically what
you see among all U.S adults 26 say kids
should be allowed to attend sex shows 52
think it should be 18 and up and nine
percent say that it should be banned out
right and among Republicans this one is
also the Unicorn this has got to be the
margin of error eight percent of
Republicans think children should be
allowed to attend sex shows fifth 58
Republicans say 18 and up only 25
percent of Republicans say banned
outright look at that divide
nearly four four in ten Democrats think
children should be allowed to attend sex
shows if that persists I just kind of
think Democrats probably won't be a
political party for a lot longer because
they're at odds with the general public
to a great degree
and independent voters I think regular
people you show them what's going on in
these videos then first of all they
don't believe it
I was talking to people about that video
of the guy pulling the baloney out of
his crotch or the zipper and the gay men
thrusting into each other I was talking
to a friend and I was like yeah but look
we're not talking about like just
someone in a costume reading a book
we're talking about children having a
dude in a thong perform like a
striptease dance or uh like on Bill
Maher when it was um Winsome Sears from
Virginia lieutenant governor saying like
look it's about what parents want their
kids to be involved like be or not be
involved in she's like I don't want my
kid getting a lap dance from a drag
queen and then Bill Mark goes well okay
they're reading books I don't think
they're giving lap dances yes they are
it's like well I must have missed this
and she goes bill you need to read you
need to read more yeah and then everyone
laughs because Bill Maher doesn't read
the news you show that to the average
person like you were saying about sanity
and they're going to be like well I
didn't know I was supporting that yeah
in North Carolina a drag queen gave a
lap dance to a child
and and we got you know Ian bought the
book genderqueer not even conservatives
are reading that book and they really
should that's funny conservatives are
like I've seen enough I know it's bad oh
you don't even know the half of it you
should read it
so I think regular people are probably
going to see this and just if we can
show them they're going to be like yeah
I'm out and the hard part is then
getting them out of their algorithm
because their algorithm is only going to
show them what they want to be seeing so
they're not going to be seeing any of
that content on their social media
platforms or anywhere a lot of the
people when I would explain that these
things were going on would be like that
that sounds ridiculous I I don't know if
that's actually nobody believes no they
don't when you tell people what like The
Cutting Edge of leftist thought is
people are like no they all every single
time I tell any average kind of like
Democrat person oh this is what's coming
out of Sociology departments right now
this is The Cutting Edge of leftist lot
they're like no way no one left you know
no one will believe it no we we really
want to get Bill Maher on this show and
there's been conversations recently
about me going on Bill Maher's show Bill
Maher is going to be in DC in five days
he's doing uh he's doing a stand-up he's
doing stand-up at the MGM National
Harbor and that's on a Saturday and I'm
just thinking you know a Friday night
it's the perfect opportunity to promote
your show bill should have have you on
the show no I'm a big fan of Bill Maher
speaking out against the stuff he's
learning about I just wish with his
platform he knew more and I think it
would be one of the most epic
conversations to be sitting here with
him because we have this big these big
monitors and when he's like I don't know
about them giving lap dances like oh
Bill yo Bill let me let me pull the
video up for you and press play and then
we'll just play it right here and he'll
watch it and he'll be like okay you're
right you know I always ask the people
who are in support of children being
able to go to drag shows and like oh
it's educational what are they learning
are they learning life skills to get
naked and to work in front of other
children like what is beneficial for a
child to go there it's literally a show
that it's about explicit over-the-top
sexual actions It's Burlesque it's it's
like it's sexualized comedy
it's a clown show I guess the fact that
it's CL it's always sexualized like
there's no drag show that isn't
sexualized so people that make the
argument oh kids really should be able
to get into this I don't I don't I don't
understand how they justify it because
just because the fact that it is clearly
sexualized uh it's they they justified
by saying it's teaching them about
inclusion that it's teaching them that
people with alternative Lifestyles exist
and they're not bad people therefore you
can send your kids to these shows and
it's nothing's gonna happen to them it's
fine it's about inclusion that's
unacceptable because it's unacceptable
to send your kids to Chip and Dales or
to the strip club with the movies I'm
giving you the but to them they don't
think past the first stage of the
argument yeah they're like oh how much
is about inclusion how much do you want
to bet Bill Maher's never seen the video
of the child strippers
that it's not going to lick itself
when when that little boy was ripping
his clothing off on stage and at a gay
bar while they handed money to him I bet
he's never seen it and that one's from
like 2018. yeah like this stuff's been
going on for a long time and the problem
is specifically people like Bill Maher
don't read the news they're like all of
this stuff is happening around the
country and obviously corporate press
covers up I was reading about the
Budweiser uh story in the Washington
Post and they lied about everything
surprise surprise they said the
boycott's not clear if there's been any
impact at all and it's like
Anheuser-Busch made it they put out a
commercial and issued a statement
clearly some things got got him worried
and their stock has gone down and
they're like well it's not clear it's
like okay that's that's an argument but
on a news report you can argue since the
controversy started anheuser-bush stock
has dropped by five points or whatever
but they don't they don't mention that
they say and then they said the whole
the whole controversy she started over a
single can of beer a promo can with
Dylan Mulvaney on it and I was like yeah
and the video of Don Mulvaney drinking
Bud Light being a brand ambassador and
dancing and the estimates that Dylan
received 50k or whatever for doing it I
don't know if that's true or whatever
but people are upset that Budweiser in
any way supported this person it's not
about a single can of beer but they need
to lie diminish and downplay so they can
keep these people trapped in a box and
unfortunately people like Bill Murray
doesn't read the news
the Nike videos were worse those were
actually like looks like he's making fun
of women they all always the the the
Nike ones to me were even more
ridiculous and I always I always really
want to stress this too Dylan Mulvaney
is not trans
like you can't just say like I mean what
if Donald Trump came out right now and
was like my fellow Americans I am now a
woman I am the first female president
Donald Donna Trump and uh they would say
no he's not he's lying right so why look
simply put they would say Donald Trump
is lying he's not trans there's no way
anyone would believe that if Trump came
out as trans anyone would support him
and even if he actually was like legit
was like no I've been hiding this all my
life and he really believed it they
would still say no you're not they would
they would deny forever no matter what
so why should I assume or just give that
benefit of the doubt to someone like
Dylan Mulvaney who I'm gonna say it
again hiking heels putting on high heels
in the forest is not something that
women or trans people do it was a clown
show comedy performance intended to mock
it was literally making fun of women it
was it was an adult male dressing like a
woman I mean to be a girl putting on
high heels and running for the woods and
then getting scared of a bug that is
like the most offensive Woman face
performance you could do
you took the words out of my mouth I was
just about to say this is essentially
blackface for Womanhood and I've seen
this clip before where Dylan was saying
how this initially started as either
comedy or satire I can't remember the
exact word to use but he is known from
the beginning that this was not a
serious thing but he's turned it into a
serious thing because it's become so
profitable and the algorithm on Tick
Tock is so aggressive with it because I
don't follow Dylan I've never liked a
single video of Dylan's I've never saved
or commented on a video of Dylan's but I
will get notifications on my phone from
Tick Tock saying that Dylan Mulvaney
just posted a new video wow and because
and I have screenshots of it too and
because of that there's going to be an
entire generation of people growing up
that are going to have mental health
crisis all because of Dylan Mulvaney's
rise to stardom this is Elsa gate 2.0
it's why I describe it as such that the
algorithm just picks things props them
up and they get weirder and crazier so
it's it's not just that it sees what you
like and then makes more of it it's that
it doesn't know what the difference is
between what you like and something with
similar words in it so on YouTube
something interesting happened where if
somebody made a video about immigration
YouTube's algorithm does not know if
you're for or against immigration all it
knows is the title said the word
immigration in it so who does it send it
to people who are for immigration or
against immigration
it doesn't know so with someone like
delmo then what happens is there are
some things that people will click
thumbs up on it doesn't know the
difference between Del Mulvaney who's
pretending and mocking and insulting
trans people and say like an actual
trans person making a real argument thus
Dylan Mulvaney's outrageous Shenanigans
and the one big important component is
the incrementation day one day two day
three that creates a a this effect in
people where they need resolution so
they always come back to see the next
number it was perfect algorithmic
manipulation and I think Dom of any knew
exactly what he was doing and I I will
stress it again we we I've talked to
some uh
I'm not going to name the individuals
but we've had the conversation with some
of our uh guests on the show who are
trans who said there's clear signs to
them that Dylan mulvania is not trans
based on the procedures and the things
that Dylan has done
that trans people don't do and or that
trans people would have done and certain
things don't move any does that trans
people would not do there have been
references to I'll give you an example
actually when Don mulvani made the video
and talked about how bulges exist and
women have bulges
what was told to me and maybe this is
just the opinion of a couple trans women
is that
a video like that would cause them
severe anxiety by triggering gender
dysphoria the idea of making a video and
pointing to your junk and saying look at
my junk like Dylan Mulvaney did is is is
the inverse of what someone with a body
dysmorphic disorder would do think about
a person who's anorexic do you think an
anorexic person would make a video where
they're like look at my roles it's okay
that I have roles I'm so fat I'm so fat
everybody look how fat I am look at this
and pinch themselves no they do the
opposite they're terrified of looking
fat to the point where they starve
themselves to death so if Dylan Mulvaney
actually fit the descriptor as most
people like as somebody with dysmorphia
they wouldn't be making videos where
they sing about having penis a bulge in
their pants it is totally fake there you
go
I never thought about it that way but it
makes sense it's yeah because gender
dysphoria is a mental illness I can't
emphasize that enough so for Dylan to be
so glorifying in it it's problematic but
it also just adds to the culture of
mental illness overall because I've
noticed that anxiety and depression have
become such a trend and even ADHD
there's people who have never been
diagnosed with any of those in their
lives so those are three very real
conditions but now it's like to fit in
you have to have some kind of mental
illness I've even had people brag about
like oh yeah I'm so bipolar haha I'm
like is that funny yeah or leave did
people who say that they have like
numerous personalities who inside
themselves and they're talking about
operating as a system basically oh this
part of my system is whatever whatever
it is literally a trend it's literally
like a tick tock thing and people post
about all the time same thing with
Tourette's tourettes is because yeah
yeah part of it is also like in a
culture now where everyone's looking for
something that makes them special or
unique that's something that they feel
like gives them some type of unique
identifier and it's just been turned in
to a weird thing through social media
you know it used to be that if you
wanted to be famous or known about you
had to do something notable
so what you'd get is you know people
turn on the radio or the TV and they'd
see actors and then people were like oh
I want to be an actor I want to be an
actor I've gone through so much of this
too I've had people hit me up and be
like you know back when I worked advice
when I was traveling around I had so
many people be like oh I really want to
do what you do oh boy and then once they
actually see what it involves like oh I
don't do that like that's not what I was
talking about I want to be on camera and
famous and I'm like okay well I'm on
camera because I like traveling and
talking to people and learning about
what's going on in these places
I'm not on camera because I want to be
on camera that's like paradoxical it's
like like you get on camera for doing a
thing not just being on camera and so
then sure enough people immediate
abandon the line of work they never want
it in the first place people are just
trying to do whatever they have they can
to get attention I find it I think that
it it's surprising to me that there are
so many people that get behind Dylan as
Dylan uh for Dylan being a trans person
I really feel like there should be more
people that would just be like that that
is not a trans person that is a person
just looking to be famous that's just
hopping on the band well I I the way I
described it is like that we're coming
to the point where there's different
kinds of transgender there is gender
dysphoric people who look in the mirror
and feel a disconnect between their body
and their biological sex and that
trigger is depressing depression and
things like that and that is the
traditional view of gender dysphoria or
transgenderism but then you have what's
called AGP and what is it AAP Auto
gynophilia and Otto androphilia these
are end individuals like the person who
wrote genderqueer friends we have the
book right there it's a biological
female who is aroused at the thought of
being male and so wants other people to
call them male because it stimulates
them which is more Kink and fetish stuff
but then you have the third chapter
which is Dylan Mulvaney who is not Trans
in any of any sense Michael I think it
was Michael Mouse who said that he
thinks it's a fetish act like AGP and
I'm like no no no it's different it's
like I think Leah Thomas the end uh that
was a NCAA swimmer there was an article
talking about how she was talking to
them in the dress
there's a bunch of posts on talking
about what they call Hep which is like
it's a kink it's a fetish it's not
gender dysphoria but Dylan Mulvaney
isn't doing that Dylan Mulvaney isn't
dysphoric as as I referenced with the
video about singing about having a bulge
a person who is dysphoric doesn't want
that so Dylan Mulvaney being proud and
saying it's okay and look at my junk is
like are you just making fun of trans
people you're clearly not dysphoric so
Dylan Mulvaney's version of trans is it
makes me famous and they're promoting
that to kids that's I'll I'll wrap up
that's why I think the Budweiser boycott
is so important because they didn't they
didn't come out in support of the LGBT
community they came out and like you
know I describe it as imagine if
Budweiser came out and sponsored a an
old school Minstrel show of like a bunch
of dudes in blackface being as racist as
possible and I'm like that's basically
what I see with Dylan Mulvaney insulting
and mocking trans people and women at
the same time to an extreme degree and
then Whoopi Goldberg in the view and all
these other institutions coming out and
defending it that's the same thing that
I said to a friend of mine he he'd uh I
made a remark about the Anheuser-Busch
comment and I said you know this means
keep keep flying pressure and uh he
objected to it and I was just like look
Dylan is not a trans person that is
helping trans people in any way the only
thing he's doing is harming people he's
not making any anyone feel bad for field
in any way sympathetic towards uh trans
people whether the gender dysphoric uh
or not and and I don't think that we
should entertain AGP at all like I don't
want to play along with your Kink right
sorry but but look at all the pride
parade events where they have like men
with dog masks full month should just be
called Kink and and it should that's
what it is when when we had uh uh I
think Destiny Omni liberal when we were
talking about Ron DeSantis and the books
that were being disallowed they say it's
a book ban yeah they're banning porn
yeah and he was like well this looks
like sex education and I'm like dude
that's a butt plug and he's like yeah
and I'm like that's not sex education
that's education yeah that is the most
ridiculous cope that I've ever heard
come out of Destiny ever like the the
the idea that it's acceptable to teach
people under 18 how butt plugs work give
me a
I I mean that is something I I'll
violate TOS if I keep going on like you
know you know we'll save it for the
members only show which is coming up in
uh you know half an hour but could you
imagine how funny it would be I wouldn't
I will say this I will be in no way
surprised at all if like
in one year's time Del Mulvaney uploads
a video of him wearing a suit and tie
with a deeper voice saying hey everybody
I just want to let you know the whole
thing was a bit to prove how insane all
of you are I'm a Conservative Christian
have been the whole time and then have
them just be like Han like the idea that
you could increasingly increment the
insanity the insults the degradation and
you would keep supporting it proves the
point so like hilarious you don't see
with Dylan Mulvaney a calm rational
person saying we just want to live like
that's the argument I like to make no
don't Mulvaney like does the most
shockingly offensive things possible the
most insulting ways possible
yeah well that's the state of things I
suppose how about that let's go to super
chats if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share this show with
your friends and head over to
timcast.com click that join us button
become a member because at 10 10 pm
eastern time we'll have a members only
uncensored show on the front page of the
website it is live and if you've been a
member for at least six months or you
sign up at the 25 level you can actually
submit questions and maybe even call
into the show we only choose about four
or five every night so I don't want to
say it's a guarantee but we try to get
as many new people in as possible and I
think it's the most fun portion of the
day
when you guys get to talk to us on the
show and of course once that wraps it's
available in the archive forever for you
to go back and watch later
all right let's jump to those super
chats
Freedom Jeffrey 1776 says hi Tim thank
you for a great show in Austin hopefully
many more to come and thank you for
letting me plug my YouTube channel
absolutely and we are going to have a
show I think the next one's gonna be in
Florida
but that won't be for a while so we're
we're
half a year away from that event but I'm
really excited for that one it should be
even bigger
all right black shadow 164 says hey Tim
big fan of the show Matt Walsh should
debate should debate Jordan klepper live
expose The Daily Show
also a Brewing Company should sponsor
Andrew Tate sure I guess that's up to
him and a brewing company uh I don't
think klepper would ever agree to do a
debate with Matt Walsh the same reason
every every one of these leftists or you
know foe left as default liberals won't
do it is because they're woefully
unprepared and incapable of Defending
indefensible ideas so
that's why I think Bill Maher is forced
to come around because you can't I so
here's the way I describe Bill Maher I
think he knew for a while that he was
playing dirty games and just siding with
liberals but you know he was able to get
away with it but there came a certain
point where it's like you cannot fool
all the people all the time so he had to
be like okay well that one's true and
then once you say that it's like okay
well that one's true okay well that one
was true okay well Trump never did that
okay I agree with you on that now he's
at the point where he's like I don't
think they're giving lap dances and when
some serious like you got to read more
and he's like okay
now he's getting to the point it's like
you can't deny it you can't pretend like
it's not happening yeah it's it's always
like the you know there's no I don't
really see personally a pipeline going
back towards left you see it
occasionally make one or two odd
YouTubers but you only see the pipeline
going towards the red pill being
awakened in The Matrix you don't see it
the other way well it's like you were
saying Xavier that uh you tried to
debunk Candace Owens and you end up
debunking yourself yeah it was a fight
for my life trying to defend or to uh
debunk those videos and what I loved
about the prageru videos especially is
because they had all their sources there
so I was going to go as deep as
debunking their sources and it was a
wild process to be honest well it's
actually really simple
in the what I call the freedom faction
you don't actually have to agree on the
opinion just the fact so if Candace
Owens comes out and says Michael Brown
never had his hands up Eric Holder is
the one who actually released the report
saying he did not have his hands up and
then if you're on the left you're saying
that's not true let me let me debunk
that and you pull it up and go oh that
act actually is true
Candace Owens opinion could be that
Darren Wilson was a good person or a bad
person but it doesn't matter the
argument is over whether the facts you
stated exists hey if it turns out if
Candace Owen said something like uh you
know she thinks that you should drink
out of glass bottles because plastic
bottles are bad for you you can be like
okay well the fact is that plastic
bottles do leak phthalates and all the
stuff but my opinion is that I don't
think it's it's the effect is that
pronounced and you're probably fine now
in reality I'm actually in favor of
glass bottles that's what we have them
but my point is Candace Owens is not
going to politically argue with you over
a minor like I guess my point is this I
sat down with um Glenn Beck and we
discussed abortion pro-life versus
pro-choice and we smiled we talked it
out we agreed on the basic facts and
then we disagree disagreed on the
philosophy of government's role and how
to deal with these things and smiled and
chickens there's no anger there's no
animosity there's no resentment it was
just like thank you for helping me
understand your opinion on moral
philosophy I don't see it that way I
disagree with you and I'm like wow I Now
understand your moral philosophy
opinion is opinion but we agree on the
facts that's that that's the thing about
where we are we can all disagree on our
opinions on where things you know should
how they should be implemented but as
long as we Grant what is we're fine the
left doesn't understand what is they
don't they believe fake things all the
time how do you how do you how can
someone have an opinion if they don't
know what actually happened they can't I
mean that's why they use terms like his
truth her truth they're trying to make
the truth objective because the only way
for them to justify their sentences or
sorry subject is or subjective is if
they are able to just move what the
facts are every single time they have a
debate about something yeah they believe
that the the truth is Downstream from
power so they believe that if they say
things they can create a world the way
they want just by speaking into reality
right Gabby Hayes says what up Brett Tim
your convo with Peter last week was nuts
and gave me chills love Tim Cass and pop
culture crisis thanks for everything you
guys do which portion of it was it the
algorithmic manipulation one or the war
one because the one I got I get super
triggered basically if anyone ever comes
to me and they're like I support war and
I'll be like okay why and then they're
like no reason at all just because the
government told me to I'm just like
that's it I'm officially angry yeah like
yeah I I do not believe you have a right
to advocate for the bombing of civilians
women children or or for that matter
even our adversaries unless you can
justify why it is in the same vein that
if a dude shoots another dude you have
to you have to justify the self-defense
you can't just be like I don't know I'll
be like no no I I agree with you right
to bear arms I agree with you right
self-defense but you can't just walk up
to a guy and attack him so if the United
States wants to use the weight of
government to go to war and that's
basically what we talked about in the
members only portion he was like why do
you here's what happened for you guys
should watch it actually if you want to
see me get triggered and talk about
Ukraine
basically what happened was
Peter burgosian uh smart smart guy is
cool guy is of the view that wokeness
derives from the universities and I said
a portion of it in terms of some of its
you know faux ideology but wokeness
itself is a result of the algorithm
manipulating people and wellness is
better described as cult-like adherence
to Liberal social Orthodoxy and then I
said the best example of this is people
putting Ukraine Flags in their bios
there is a one for one for the most part
overlap between woke people and support
for the war in Ukraine and then he said
I don't understand why you're lumping
those things together and I was like
because there's literally no reason to
support war in Ukraine there's like a
few neocon neolib arguments about
Russian expansionism whatever but
whenever I ask any of these people why
should I care about Estonia they can't
give me an answer there's like well but
you're up I'm like bro that's not an
answer is Estonia delivering us grain do
they deliver us fertilizers is it going
to deeply impact our economic situation
give me an answer they don't have one
and so my point is if you've got someone
claiming critical race Theory critical
gender theory pro-war in Ukraine and
Trump sucks there's clearly no link
between these things in University it's
all algorithms and then from that he
said he disagreed he supports the war in
Ukraine and then I said okay I think
this is Ukraine derangement syndrome who
had this like two hour long debate over
it was good it was good I thought it was
good
yeah uh you know it is what it is all
right you guys should watch it so I
don't just rehash the whole thing and
then we'll read some more hillbilly
Clinton says if it wasn't for the
algorithms I would have never found your
show a few years ago when I did so at
least they did something right love you
all God bless
yes I agree with that but here's the
thing we are like booted from the
algorithm now
so uh what what basically happens
actually let me let me give you a really
good example if you've noticed uh this
channel has I think like 1.46 million
subscribers despite the fact that we get
like a million plus views per day and we
are consistently the most viewed live
show I think I think we have on average
the highest live audience every single
night Monday through Friday on YouTube
in the night slot in in the night slot
right there's other shows that get way
more views and if like Red Bull doesn't
mean you'll get like millions of live
viewers but we consistently average way
higher than most people how is it that
we don't have the same level of
subscriber growth than a bunch of these
other channels on the left that get no
views
so like I wonder I wonder you know what
I mean and it's obvious people complain
all the time that even though they're
subscribers and they watch every day
YouTube won't send them a notification
for the show and they have to go and try
and find it many people have pointed out
that even when we are live they can't
find the link so you know we have to do
to counter this timcast.com now plays
the embedded live show on timcast.com so
whenever people are like yo it's not
even popping up on your YouTube channel
it's like go to timcast.com it's there
and then they're able to watch it
despite the fact that YouTube's doing
something they're doing something
so yeah
that's the game they play all right
sideways says just found Xavier's
Channel and count it like a week ago big
fan and I'm really glad you were able to
see things from both sides what kinds of
content would you recommend to show what
you discovered
well definitely prageru.com those five
minute videos are incredible and even
the archives of like the Candace Owens
show that I would watch on their
um fireside chat Unapologetic with amla
she is amazing all of those will give
you really just quality context and
they'll also give you the sources so
that you can do your own research
because we don't want you to just watch
our videos and have that be the end-all
be-all but if you go through those five
minute videos it's much more productive
than going to a university half the time
now the stories of us videos are good
too with people telling their stories
about how they noticed culture is
changing yeah my stories of Us video
just came out last week so please go
watch that on preview.com and if you
have kids go to prageru kids.com they
have kids content where it's all about
you know American values history and
none of the woke propaganda that you're
seeing on Channel or channels like
Disney now so highly recommend going to
prageru kids.com if you're a parent
all right Raymond g Stanley Jr said Don
Jr was just on the show talking about
not backing down now because of
donations he wants folks to back down
why does the right lose because people
like Don Jr take uh people like John Jr
take a walk down junior I like Don Jr
and I gotta be honest I listened uh to a
bit of his argument and I I I was
actually almost convinced because I was
thinking like
the media is reporting that Budweiser
apologized even though they didn't and
I'm like is that a PR Victory I mean it
might be enough for the for the
narrative when when the media is saying
Budweiser apologizes
they didn't but you could call it that
because they said we didn't mean to be
divisive which shows regret for
sponsoring Dylan Mulvaney in which case
it's like
do you do you do you do you take the win
right now even though it's not the win
you're hoping for but you can claim it
as a victory or do you push it harder
and maybe you know double risk you know
double or nothing and lose it all
in the end however I think
the end result should be if they really
do sponsor Republicans or don't tell
Republicans more then we actually have
more leverage Don Junior's argument
should be the inverse he should be
saying double down on your boycott
because it turns out Budweiser is
desperate for Republican support
this means we can easily win this one so
here's my point
if Budweiser really is scared and it's
the easiest thing in the world in terms
of the culture War battle to win because
all you gotta do is buy a different beer
and Tack onto the fact that Budweiser
actually depends on Republicans for
their support legislatively
that just means that it's twice as easy
to win now what should happen is Don
Junior should have come out and said oh
hey bud you know you're sponsored about
your Republicans here's what I'm going
to do I'm going to go to all those
Republicans and time to kick your money
back unless you apologize then Budweiser
would be like okay you win because they
don't give money for nothing they're
giving money to Republicans because they
expect something to happen for them if
these Republicans said no no no no
Budweiser Anheuser Bush you get nothing
from us anymore no penny is going to
earn you any favors because I will lose
my re-election if I support you
I'll let's make let's let's one-up this
all right ladies and gentlemen
here's one thing you can do first if you
really want to win this one it's simple
don't buy Anheuser-Busch products until
they formally apologize
two if you're more keen to be productive
and active
find out if your local representative
Senator Congressman mayor whoever is a
republican that receives any kind of
funding from Anheuser-Busch or from a
political action committee or Super PAC
that receives money from Anheuser-Busch
and then demand that politician reject
that funding
or denounce it at the very least if a
Pac is receiving funding from
Anheuser-Busch and then you can support
Republican demand of those Republicans
they denounce those packs
that will send chills down the spine of
the CEO of Anheuser-Busch and they'll
apologize in two seconds because that
means they're going to lose like make it
politically toxic for any politician to
associate in any way with Anheuser-Busch
that's what Don Jr should have said oh
they need our help they're they're
paying for it I I'm sorry man I like Don
Jr but how spineless was it to be like
guys guys but they give us money I don't
care that means they need something from
you look if I had a customer
come into my bakery and say I I pay my
bills you better do as I say I'd be like
you know what I just found out I don't
need your money get out your band for
life don't come in here and spit in my
face you know what I mean like a
contract between two parties is a mutual
exchange your money helps my business
but my business provides a service for
you in exchange imagine calling a
plumber over to your house and then just
insulting him the whole time and then
he's like well I'm gonna leave no you
can't leave no no no
you can't do that you can't do it I'm
sorry man put the pressure on anyway
let's read some more
all right what do we got here
Corey says boycott has Bush between a
rock and a hard place we are right at
summertime cookouts fishing parties Etc
they need to feel the hurt and we're
close no joke it was so beautiful out
today it was a crisp 60 degrees the
trees are all green the pollen was
everywhere now sneezing up a storm but
we're already talking about when we're
gonna have this barbecue maybe Friday
have a barbecue I need to call it
barbecue but a grill a grill you know
get a bunch of burgers we got the picnic
table outside cook it get some yeah
cookout yeah we're going to get some
beers am I invited to the coast
absolutely yeah
and uh but you got to bring the beer and
you're not and you're not bringing
Anheuser I want it in the first place I
have self-respect so uh we'll do a big
cookout you know what we should do you
know what we should do
we should do a really big cookout like
an event we should find a local park
plan it for like a week or two and then
maybe it would have to be this weekend
like on a Saturday see if we can just be
like we're doing a big meet up we're
gonna Grill everybody's invited
bring the beer and not Anheuser we'll
set a 50 000 budget for this for our
beer and we'll build a mountain of Coors
Light and I'll stress this too people
have pointed out that Coors has done
Pride commercial stuff oh I don't care
about that literally don't care if an
alcohol beverage is advertising to
adults who are lgbtq that's that's great
they're people they drink beer that's
fine yeah it's Dylan Mulvaney Dylan
Mulvaney is insulting and advertising
stuff to Children I'm not not get out of
here not interested not interested yeah
it's not the same thing people are often
conflate it it's just not the same
all right let's see we got
sir neoff Strife says hey Tim have you
been watching Picard season three they
got a new director so far it's been a
love letter to the T to uh the Next
Generation fans since you talk about the
Next Generation a lot I think you'll
like it I highly recommend watching
episode nine because it comments on
Modern culture War they just pointed out
I think I've been watching it but I
don't think I've seen episode nine
um I skipped season two though
yeah season two was the one where they
go back in time to stop Trump is that
what it was yeah I I have a rule that
you get one episode to hook me if you
can't hook me in one season you don't
get a season two well the first one I
thought was fun because it was just like
hey remember this remember that and I'm
like oh it's a good old days you know
then season two is like something
happened in the past that turned Earth
into an earth supremacist country we
have to go back in time and stop Donald
Trump from winning the presidency
that's just like okay dude I'm not gonna
watch that and I didn't
so you know whatever
but uh season three I'm is fine
um although I vaguely remember it at
this point yeah
I don't know what is it like they're
they commandeered some ship they tricked
some guy and then they're chasing after
Picard's son or something none of the
none of the new stuff I am finally
starting Stargate though Stargate sp1 is
amazing I'm finally I'm finally forcing
myself to because I had seen season one
and I'm now starting to make my way
through it a little bit at a time it's
cool because they take like sci-fi
conspiracy and turn it into a show you
know
so a lot of these weird kooky I hate
calling them conspiracy theories because
believing that aliens planted the seeds
of life on Earth isn't a conspiracy like
the aliens didn't come together and say
no one cares no it's like it's not
criminal in any way it's just like a
weird hypothesis I guess so outlandish
theories yeah I'm not sure but is it
even outlandish or is just like
like highly improvised obscure obscure
improbable theories there you go I guess
you could like absurd would be like Flat
Earth or something absurd would be
flattered yeah yeah I like donut Earth
theory the Earth is both flat and hollow
hollow flatten Hollow it's a donut
you know donut Earth there's actually
pictures online of donut Earth yeah it's
clearly not a donut because you'd see
the gap of the donut when you like went
to certain places you'd be like looking
forward and you'd see a floating column
in the sky you know did somebody like
fall through the hole in the donut if
they just walk off the edge what would
the gravity be like if Earth was a donut
could you like float in the middle
would there be air over to the other
side I suppose like there would be a
spot in the center where you could be
suspended it's both flat and Hollow
Aaron Preston says Phil two weeks and
this calling our absolute Banger songs
your transition from Scream to clean is
amazing cheers thank you very much I
appreciate that and we're just listening
to it uh before the show because I took
all that remains in the weekend and I
merged the voices into one voice and it
was like just a different voice it
didn't work I don't know we should do a
little more though yeah we used 11 labs
to take clips of the weekend and All
That Remains and put them together and
it was just it sounded like a weird guy
I don't know there was a little bit of
them in there yeah and there was also a
weird Distortion in the background I
think from the music playing maybe yeah
Let's see we got
super 503 dank says have this guest back
for the culture War podcast it'd be a
good one uh I agree yeah we should uh
have you back for the Friday morning
show and we can talk about like all the
BLM stuff more one-on-one sounds good to
me yeah this one's more of like the news
subject of the day and stuff all right
kcb says just paid 120 bucks for 24
Ultra ripe beers so be it I think I'm
gonna order some yeah yeah I think I
should you know because we normally uh
go to local breweries and we stock up on
beer for guests with just you know but
uh everybody's been very good about not
drinking alcohol and not drinking beer
and so we just never got more but uh you
know some guests like a nice a nice beer
we'll get the ultra right there's a lot
of people on the right that have have
moved away from drinking alcohol and
stuff like that I think a lot of people
in general have like Whoopi Goldberg
said she quit drinking yeah yeah I think
people just don't drink it comes up at
least once in episode it seems like it
comes up for me at least once an episode
that I have to end up mentioning that
like being in recovery just means no
drinking so Bud Light doesn't really
affect me at all yeah yeah but I did
have a uh an apple cider this weekend
not you know like I'll drink
periodically and it was fun hanging out
with the boys playing poker and having
an apple cider so that was good fun got
a cooler a couple times but won some
money was had a good time
all right Daniel says I'm a black
progressive metal rock musician but I've
always been considered an outsider for
some reason I don't know what it takes
to break the mold of the stereotypes by
the way Tim are you bringing in
musicians to help with the movement and
culture yes
um we got a couple songs in the works
we're talking about doing a cover maybe
yeah we're gonna do uh Phil's helping
out with one of the songs that we like
half wrote I think we're doing pain on
Wednesday oh yeah cool yeah it's a riff
that I really like it's like a story
that I really like for a song but it's
not one that I felt like I could do
Phil's gonna do it your courses are good
I'll just do some Versa stuffs some
shouty stuff it'll come it'll come on
cool yeah we'll see and then uh Carter's
got a preliminary version of like an
electric dance song that we're putting
together so we were we started with a
few songs we did three songs of mine and
we're trying to advance into other areas
and bring in more people you know who I
would absolutely just absolutely love to
get to to work with on guitar and I
don't even know it's possible but I'm
just gonna say it uh what's his is it
Josh Farrow the former Paramore
guitarist I don't know yeah I think
that's his name yeah
he's got he wrote good guitar and I'm
thinking I'm like I'm just gonna say it
because maybe there's a possibility I'm
assuming he's a trump supporter
just watching yeah yeah who knows who
knows but he had some of the best like
some really amazing guitar stuff let's
uh let's let's do cool cool things man
let's read some more uh super chats
Reed Weber says Florida passed a bill
that would allow for the death penalty
for sexual assaults on kids 12 and under
I know you opposed the death penalty but
I'm cheering
my issue is not with okay so here's
here's the thing you gotta understand
uh someone who abuses children you're
like they should get the death penalty
I'm like okay I hear you I totally
understand my issue is not whether or
not you think the crime justifies death
it's whether or not the state can
actually prove the crime and the idea of
someone like Kamala Harris being in
charge of murdering people freaks me out
that's simply put I say it like this all
the time I I don't endorse the state
killing people but that doesn't mean
that there aren't people that haven't
earned death like there are plenty of
people that deserve to die people who
kill other people people children
torture rape murder war criminals like
there's a reason why the death penalty
is a thing that through due process it
is determined that you have forfeit your
right to life because of the egregious
crimes against the world the problem is
like if if I'm if if I'm dealing with
like a war or if I see a guy like
literally about to kill a child like you
got to stop that person you don't want
them to die but you're going to do what
you have to do to save that child's life
or the victim or whatever the problem is
when you take a guy up I'm I walk into a
courtroom and I sit down and Kamala
Harris goes see this guy over here
well he beat a kid so he should die and
I'm like lady I don't believe you I I
don't believe you like sorry don't get
me wrong there are people who point out
there's like sometimes it's extremely
definitive and I'm like that's that's
the thing right
it's like there's ten Witnesses here's a
clean two-hour live stream of the guy
doing it he then runs at the camera says
his name his date of birth and his
social security number and it's like
okay or well that I get but that's like
not how it really works so the issue is
it is better that 10 guilty persons
Escape than one innocent person suffer
and if the system is in place as such
that innocent people can be put to death
I just can't support it end of story
all right all right we'll read some more
Super chats uh
the one that one gamer says I heard you
guys talk about religion a lot recently
I'd like to recommend Michael Jones of
inspiring philosophy he's openly he's
willing to come on the show could be a
great show I think that would be great
for the culture War podcast maybe what
we should do we should get him on with
Ian
and Sheamus Sheamus is back this weekend
by the way is he yeah I don't know how
long he's gonna be around for but uh
We've we successfully tricked him we
told him that uh we got him an all
expenses paid trip to the Bahamas for
vacation but really we're gonna have the
airline reroute him back here and then
when he lands he won't know and we're
gonna Shuffle him into a car and then
drive him here and then he won't realize
till it's too late smart the work and
then he'll just you know wake up in here
and he'll be like where am I what's
going on and we'll be like be funny
you know
thousand-foot defense as people who
wonder if the glass is half empty or
half full missed the point the glass is
refillable unknown true I like that one
that's good that's nice the glass is
refillable unless like you're in the
desert you know then you're then you're
in trouble then all you've got is water
left because of climate change and it's
just yes the glass can't be filled at
all or it's too full the pessimism will
just always win through for that type of
person if you're pessimistic it's never
going to change for a lot of them Peter
a says Scott Galloway was on Modern
wisdom and in his interview he both
States he's on the far left his words
and his goal in life is to be effing
Rich also his words they will come for
him too what a what a paradoxical
statement I don't think these people
know exactly what they're talking about
who's that they said Scott Galloway the
guy who tweeted about drag shows for
kids yeah and he said conservatives are
living in a different Century it's like
the 22nd century they're in the future
because in the future the stuff's not
going to be allowed these people keep
saying stuff like we're you're on the
wrong side of history and I'm like I'm
kind of not convinced that's true dude
because the polls suggest you are you
know
yeah I watched a video at the red yard
made the uh what if all history guy
about like the future and how he's
pointing out that like people that are
triggered by how strong disgust is a
trigger and people are they're making
this faction the left is making a
faction of people that are all like the
deplorables essentially literally the
basket of deplorables and then saying
you know love us be our friends we're
the one we're the ways to go but it just
doesn't history if you know history it
doesn't turn out like that yeah it never
does all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button then head over to timcast.com
click join us become a member to help
support our work support our cultural
Endeavors but more importantly you will
get access as a member to the members
only uncensored show which will be live
in about 10 minutes on the front page of
timcast.com and if you've been a member
for at least six months or sign up at
the 25 level you get instant access to
the VIP chat room where you can submit
questions and possibly be one of our
nightly callers to actually talk with us
and our guest it's the most fun thing of
the night in my opinion of the whole day
so I'm really excited to have y'all call
in it's the it is it's the most
interesting but uh also coffee shop is
currently underway in West Virginia
we're going to have a gaming Club social
club with some poker tables we're
working on getting licensing for actual
cash games it's going to be uh one of
the most fun things ever and I'm very
confident when I went to MGM National
Harbor
I was playing uh all 1-3 Texas Hold'em a
lot of people there knew who I was and
were fans and it was really cool to play
a couple games with some fans and I'm
fairly confident that the social club is
going to be a huge success we're gonna
be able to bring people together who are
like-minded and building that Community
is the most important thing because
you're in a culture War you gotta make
culture so remember at timcast.com smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel you can follow us at timcastirl
on Instagram and Facebook or wherever
else you can follow me personally at
timcast Xavier do you want to shout
anything out of course thank you again
for having me uh you can find me on
Instagram Xavier it's a regular spelling
it's
x-a-v-i-a-e-r and you can find me on
Twitter at xavierd
right on I am philibonti Phil that
remains on Twitter Phil that remains
official on Instagram the band is All
That Remains atrhq on Twitter All That
Remains on Instagram
perfect uh guys if you'd like to follow
me you can follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at Brett dasovic on both and
please join me and Mary on pop culture
crisis Monday through Friday 3 P.M
Eastern Standard Time right here on
YouTube see there goes
uh I'd also like to shout out Carter
Banks father guy Banks he was really
nice to us on uh the trip back in uh
Texas and it is his birth there was his
birthday on Sunday shouts out thank you
man I appreciate it um that's all I'm
searched.com follow me if you want to
right on we will see you all over at
timcast.com in about 10 minutes thanks
for hanging out